foreign
okay
Peter
okay we're gonna get underway in a few
minutes wait till everybody gets settled
in
everything
okay good morning everybody why don't we
start with uh representative coulon
allegiance to the play of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
okay so for today uh for environment
agriculture first I want to welcome
everybody here
and thank you everybody for uh
coming this morning and braving the
elements to uh to have our discussions
this morning
um the way that I have planned the day
is that
from 9 30 until
I guess noon we can discuss
um four bills ahead of us here HB 221 HP
253 HB 56 hb602 and maybe if time allows
any other questions on any other bills
um so for this morning we'll have a
committee work session I'm planning
lunch from 9 to 1 pm from 1 to 1 30
we'll have some time for each of our
sides to caucus
and then at 1 30 we will have our exec
session on a list of bills that has been
noticed
so I'd like to start with discussion on
relative to the acquisition of
agricultural
agricultural land development rights
and representative Bixby has presented
an amendment to the committee which I'd
like to have him explain and go over and
we can have discussion on it so
representative Bixby good morning good
morning
uh so uh this this amendment was uh put
together uh between uh in cooperation
between commissioner Jasper and the um
representatives of the um New Hampshire
land trust Coalition and the
um
and uh
the American Farmland trust and
um the uh and uh the primary person who
helped write it was Jeremy Lucci of the
southeast Land Trust
uh and then they ran it by various
lawyers to make sure that they'd gotten
all the
um I started in Jesus crossed so um
the uh the first section is uh
basically just giving uh adding one more
spot on the
um uh land preservation agricultural
lands preservation committee uh and so
that makes eight members rather than uh
seven and uh then it would add a member
from the New Hampshire land trust
Coalition appointed by the governor
um and uh then all the appropriate
re-lettering
um
the next section is what was the
previous uh the entire previous bill
which is that uh
the uh the changes in the second
sentence there the agricultural land
development rights purchase personal
pursuance to this section shall be held
in the name of the state of New
Hampshire or the deed shall stipulate
that the state shall have the right to
enforce the terms of the deed and that
basically
means that
um
the uh the department uh can participate
in land preservation with other entities
like the
um uh it can either it can either be
um from the federal level like uh so
with grants through the um nrcs National
National Conservation Resource Council
or uh or USDA or it can be uh with
um
uh with uh private organizations like
one of the state land trusts
um but that it'll basically allows the
um that sort of cooperation and it says
that there that uh any deed that is made
in cooperation with those other bodies
uh
the uh
uh the states rights acquired pursuant
to the uh to the purchase of the to the
to the purchase agreement should not be
sold or otherwise conveyed to a third
party so that basically means that
um
the uh the state has control if it's a
if it's a deed that has multiple uh
holders on it then uh this basically
says that the states rights need to
follow this and uh the states and what
happens to the states rights it's not
binding on say Federal Federal rights or
on
um
land private land trust rights uh and uh
and uh the next paragraph uh basically
uh indicates that the
um
the deed uh that that any
um that restricts restriction
restrictions can be built into the deed
so
um agricultural preservation restriction
shall be in perpetuity except as
released pursuant to this section and as
they may be further set forth in the
terms of the Deeds so
um if there's a if the restrictions are
released they are they not only have to
meet with the terms of this section but
also uh with the terms of the deed and
uh the next uh paragraph is
um
uh is
once again
in makes that separation between the
state's interest and other other
potential interests so that
um this statute basically governs the
state interest other interests are
um are governed by uh by the deed
um
and uh paragraphs two and three are
basically para they're parallel one
dealing with agricultural interest
preservation the other is interest in
development rights
um and on the fifth section is
um
if they're uh
if there's if there's a release of the
of the restrictions uh
they have any any release of those
restrictions has to be consistent with
the terms of the deed uh
so that is
um basically what the what the amendment
does uh the overall effect of this is to
make it possible for the
um
for the state's land agricultural land
preservation program to uh
get matching funds from the federal
government to preserve more agricultural
land uh and that's and that preservation
of land is a contract between the
current land holder uh landowner and the
state and any other uh uh public or
private interests that are involved in
on in that sale so if there were there
it's conceivable there could be money
from an ncrs Grant there could be money
from the southeast land trust and there
could be money from the state from the
Department of Agriculture provided as
matching funds for the
um for uh for the federal portion and
all of those parties would be uh would
have an interest in the deed and would
be able to enforce the restrictions of
it uh so
um
so there's basically this the net effect
is it's going to make it more possible
for the state to help with land
preservation there's there's also
currently about a million and a third
dollars in uh earmarks at the Department
of Agriculture for matching grants to
get Federal money uh to help with this
Pro with this process and that money
uh representative kantoy you have a
question uh yes um just a couple of
comments uh directed towards
representative Bixby on this amendment
if you don't mind Madam sure go right
ahead thank you
um represent Bixby on page two
um section uh the first section where it
says
the state's rights Acquired and it says
otherwise conveyed to a third party
without consent to the landowner
now the landowner I'm assuming is the
person who allowed
the deed to go forth is that correct
um so uh station
um shall not be sort of
is either the person who made the who
made that initial deed with the state or
if the property would had been was
transferred at some later Point than the
deed restrictions would be binding on a
further odor of the land
so just to be sure what you're saying is
is that if there is a family and one of
the parties enters into this deed they
are considered the landowner
and if it is their wish to pass on that
land to their another member of their
family they would then be the landowner
in this section is that correct yes
thank you yes so there so any any
transfer of ownership would transfer the
all of the restrictions and the deed and
the state can't do anything uh without
and the the state
um
uh has to consult uh with the landowner
whoever the current landowner is before
follow-up yep thank you
um also in here it seems to me that even
though preserving agricultural land is
important there is a provision in here
that it could go to development
is that correct
um
this actually reduces the possibility of
that uh so the way that the law is
currently uh there is a possib the the
state has the capacity to if there is a
determination that the land is no longer
suitable for farming and that
determination would be done by the
committee that's referenced on the first
page uh then uh it is possible to
essentially extinguish the state's
rights uh the state's interest in that
property under current law what this
would do is that in any situation where
uh the
where the land is owned jointly by say a
land trust and uh money used for the
through the ncrs or uh then uh the state
could say we don't have an interest in
it anymore but those other uh those
other interests would still have the
capacity to require that the deed be
maintained
with the restrictions okay one more one
more go ahead thank you so
um the part here it says here
uh
the site is no longer suitable for
agricultural purposes
um
and I can understand that there would be
some instances where land would not be
suitable for agricultural purposes at
one point in time but if it was led to
if it was worked and reworked and
over the course of some years it would
then be suitable again for agricultural
purposes
so
um
because you know at one point we were on
we had a lot of Farmland we let it grow
up so right now a lot of it's not
suitable for farming but if you reclaim
a lot of that it then becomes suitable
for agricultural purposes
um so I'm just wondering
um how something would be determined
that it wasn't suitable when we know
that
you can make almost any land suitable
for agricultural purposes if you take
the time right and and so that that is
um that is that that section about if
it's no longer suitable for agricultural
purposes is part of current law it's not
we're not uh and what we're essentially
what we're doing is we're putting more
restriction on that uh and uh the uh in
terms of who makes that determination uh
the uh the landowner would uh petition
the agricultural lands preservation
committee and that committee would make
a determination about uh its suitability
but for any and and that is a process
that can happen with any agricultural
land that is currently under a deed that
was created with this program as it
stands uh and that that part of it won't
change but uh any for any going forward
that is done uh jointly with another
um
another entity uh the state cannot
unilaterally uh say it's not suitable so
it actually creates better prediction
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair um so with respect to lines 25
through 27 on page uh two okay when
we're talking about uh repayment of a
landowner owner is there a time
uh frame in which the repayment has to
be made and and who is tracking that uh
receipt of monies back
um I believe that that is something that
would that is covered under department
rules and the commissioner could
probably explain how that would work but
any other questions representative
Creighton
I guess ma'am
um
and this is for uh representative Bixby
so just to to backtrack
um and make sure I got this in my head
if we do not pass this bill
then those lands would not the state
could not assist with funding in
assistance of those lands that's correct
so the is for so in any for any new
purchase of agricultural lands uh the
department uh the department has money
that is available strictly as matching
grant money which means that it would
have to be used in order to bring in
more federal funds and
um because the federal the fed the the
ncrs in particular has said that they
would not entertain any application Any
Grant application unless we had this uh
this change done to the law
okay great and for a follow-up man sure
uh
and so let me just read back what you
said to make sure it's straight in my
head
uh
so with this bill the state then helps
the landowner in accordance with the
current deed
uh it's actually so the the process for
for
um
if you want to it's it's it's
um basically what's called a
conservation easement or uh and the what
the uh the process is a landowner would
approach the state uh and potentially uh
on land trust uh also and say I have
this land that uh I would like to have
preserved as agricultural land forever
and ever and can you help me with that I
you know I can't you know I can't just
give it away because it does I can't
just give the the rights away because it
does have value so uh
so there would be an appraisement of the
value of the development rights right
and then a new deed would be uh written
that would sell just those development
rights but not any other ownership
rights uh to a combination of the state
and whatever other granting agency uh
was providing money uh for that sale
okay and then uh
and then the state and those other
agencies those other bodies would uh
have the responsibility to make sure
that
uh in the future that preservation of
the land is agricultural use would be
maintained so in terms of the Deeds
right and so the terms of the deed yes
okay great thanks Jeff sure any other
questions representative datsey good
morning
uh I'm familiar with conservation
easements okay and my understanding of
putting a conservation easement on a
piece of property is that it's pretty
irrevocable very difficult to break so
now I'm a little confused because you're
talking about this is basically being a
deed which is a conservation easement
but at some point the land owner can say
I want to develop it and I'm going to
pay you back money is that where do I
get this wrong
um okay so uh you're familiar with
familiarity with conservation easements
comes from ones that have been done in
the last say 20 years or so the original
law was written in the 1980s when the
mechanisms for conservation easements
hadn't been very worked very well worked
out and they weren't being done for
agricultural land
so uh
so the this the original legislation
set up a program
and the way they set it up then made it
possible to reverse to to reverse it
under certain conditions if the if this
committee said yes and what
so
what this bill is doing is essentially
bringing that more up to date so that uh
any
uh
any land that was acquired for where the
development rights were acquired uh
going forward
would uh
using the state's money plus money from
other places
would not uh the the state could not
unilaterally say we're taking it out of
the easement uh the state the state only
has the control over the state's rights
in it so the state could say so let's if
the state wanted to extinguish its
rights in a property that it held
jointly with the southeast Land Trust
then
it could say okay the state doesn't have
an interest in this anymore but the land
trust will maintain all of its interests
so this is actually making a much
Solider
um conservation easement or agricultural
easement on the land than current law
allows
representative
thank you madam chair
um representative Bixby is my
understanding that a lot of conservation
easements in the past were done through
l-chip which is a completely different
program than this is that correct
yes this is a very this is a completely
different program from l-chip it
actually precedes l-chip and most of the
things that are preserved under it now
uh got preserved before l-chip came on
representative nebb thank you um I have
a question for you representative Bixby
it's
it's easement through this process I
mean to representative come to us Point
sometimes
something might be farmed for a time and
then not and then goes back into farming
uh I if if it if the land goes into
essentially just goes into a natural
state that would not be
prevented by the um by the deed or that
at least
there that might be subject to deed
stipulations but I suspect that they
would not stipulate that you couldn't
just let it go fallow uh that uh I don't
think they would say you must Farm it
you can't put new buildings on it for
representative Murray
thank you madam chair um this question I
guess is for representative Bixby as
well so I'm looking here at section uh
RSA 432 uh colon 25 just regarding
development and I didn't really see
anything uh any language in there
regarding repayment so is this new
language that you would be inserting
into that area
um or where would this be going okay so
um
so what you
in the amendment before you anything
that is in ordinary type is existing
language okay
uh so the new stuff is
bold italics uh strikeouts are obviously
struck out
so perhaps I I guess to that point
you're saying that the repayment portion
is in another RSA or in another section
not in Colon 25 or 4.
um
it is in
uh
uh it's in 432.
okay
representative thank you madam chair
um just in the interest of time we have
another four bills to get through but I
personally would like to propose that we
adopt this amendment and as we go into
the executive session as this would be
the final bill on HB 221 and I
just want to record I would feel okay
about recommending this I don't know how
others feel okay thank you for that
representative burlog
for this uh thank you madam chair uh
representative Bixby for this bill to
arise was there any previous
complications in having the land owner
enter a private contractual agreement
with the buyer as to
uh honor stipulations with you know uh
said deed because what this does now
not only the buyer will have to abide by
the stipulations of the deed now they'll
have to abide by the agricultural
preservation restrictions so now we're
essentially given the state
even more control with what the buyers
can do with their land is that is that
accurate uh not quite so the the the the
landowner so this is this is a voluntary
program that a landowner chooses to uh
enter and the landowner is actually the
seller of and what they sell is not the
entire land but they sell the
development rights to the on the land so
they say uh you can so and the deed
would would the deed would specify what
those rights are uh what the what
develop exactly what the shape of those
development rights would be uh and there
are some fairly standard things that
that uh either that the state and the um
and other granting agencies would say uh
would have to be in the deed in order to
to make that qualify but so for instance
if you sell the development rights
um on your farmland
you wouldn't be able to then put in a
block of residential housing there you
wouldn't be able to put in a um
you you wouldn't be able to put in you
know a business you know a business
building you could depending on how the
deed was written you could potentially
put in like a new barn
a follow-up Madam chair
I'm sorry
so so why couldn't that just be a
private again contractual agreement with
the seller and that and then the buyer
okay so uh when uh
when it's uh an agreement between say
justice say well just use the southeast
Land Trust as an example so if there's a
um if there is a uh agreement Just
Between the southeast land trust and a
buyer then uh it would that would be
entirely private however there is
federal money available in order to uh
to make these this this sort of land
um land protection more accessible
and uh so the federal government will
not
uh there's also State money that is
designated just as matching funds for
the federal uh for the federal money so
uh and uh the Southeastern land trust
you know they have donors but they they
they can't buy yes if they have access
to if there's access to Federal money to
help out then they can preserve more
land so
um
so
uh the uh if a buyer approaches the
South Eastland trust and says I'd like
to preserve this land they said they
could say let's see if we can get some
federal money to do that and get the the
state to help us get that Federal money
okay representative thank you I I think
the simplest way to put this
representative brilliard is each deed is
separate and each landowner can
stipulate what they want in that deed
nothing is uniform so they can choose or
they cannot choose and they can put in
any stipulation they want in that deed I
think that's one of the reasons I'm okay
with it because it's not just what the
state is saying the landowner gets to
yeah representative
yeah I was just gonna sort of add to
that if I can make a comment that yes
that's true I mean you could put in hoop
houses like usually for agricultural
easements you put in a lot of language
that allows Farmers the most flexibility
on the land and an easement is always
held by somebody whether it's held by
the state or Southeast Land Trust so
when a property is sold or bequeathed to
the next person it always comes with
that easement on it and there's always
some you know primary easement holder
sometimes there's a the town is a
secondary easement holder of the state
would be a secondary easement holder
it's never you know it's just probably
like having an easement that allows a
utility company to go across your
property it's always part of the sale so
it's not you know it's not ever a
private transaction that would be
between the first landowner and the
second representative Murray uh thank
you and if I'm reading this correctly to
under to your point or my initial
question it's in uh 432 colon 24
regarding release of uh land and so um
it does say here that uh public funds
may be released so it's not necessarily
the case that that would happen because
it's permissive language there correct
it's not necessary that the
um agricultural land development rights
board that meets would necessarily
release it
assumes up to the discretion of that
board yes the the board would make any
decision about any
um what would be what's called
extinguishment
um but the way that what this bill does
is it says that the state can only
extinguish their interest in it they
can't so if there are other interests
okay any other questions or comments
seeing none
um I think uh it's pretty clear uh that
we will be executing this bill later
this afternoon with this amendment
so uh I would like to move on now
to
um
a discussion on HB 253
establishing a committee to study
extended producer responsibility
um
representative Bixby you had some
language here that was that maybe uh
something that you want to put together
as an amendment for this bill but has
not been drafted as an amendment is that
correct that's correct okay would you
like to uh go over that with the
committee today sure uh so one of the
things that uh came up in the hearing is
that it seemed like the
um
the language in terms of the duties was
not and well actually I'm going to deal
with one thing very quickly uh there the
numbers are the the original Bill asked
for two members of the Senate we never
managed to get two members of the Senate
if we send over to send it over to the
Senate with that in it they will send it
back uh with an amendment saying we only
we're only going to give you one Senator
so
um so I think we might as well take the
work off work away from them and just do
that here okay um agree with that so so
that's the easy part
um and then the uh in terms of the
duties uh I think there was a general
sense that the duties that were laid out
um
in the original Bill were not
um quite specific enough and uh it it uh
gave a little bit and there was a desire
for a little bit more Direction uh so
um
I maintained the general idea that
um we that the committee would you know
look at
um look at epr in terms of waste
reduction and in terms of reducing the
tax burden uh because that is that is an
important part of it uh we don't we
wouldn't want to suggest epr legislation
that would somehow increase the tax
burden
um and that and and decreasing the tax
burden is certainly one of uh several
motivations for doing this sort of uh
legislation
um
and there are a number of laws in other
in other states and in Canada in Europe
that uh
that uh deal with extended producer
responsibility in a broad range of areas
including packaging single-use Plastics
beverage containers electronic waste
batteries automotive waste hazardous
waste there are some there are other
ones too I just this is
um I this list is not intended to be
exhaustive
uh and uh rather than
um Reinventing the wheel it would
probably make sense to see what's out
there and see what might be adaptable to
New Hampshire uh so
um
and so that so uh one uh specific job of
the committee would be to look at laws
and other jurisdictions and see what we
might be able to uh use in New Hampshire
um and uh which is
um
and then uh the next step is looking at
how look at looking at the process of
adapting those lots in New Hampshire and
one thing that would be critical to that
would be working with the Department of
Environmental Services to make sure that
uh they would be able to implement
whatever we
um whatever we put together I had the
um I had a learning learning experience
several terms ago putting a bill in for
electronic waste
epr and uh discovering that uh the way
they do it in Vermont just wouldn't work
in New Hampshire because the way our uh
because of the structure of our transfer
stations and our recycling centers and
municipalities and the way that uh that
the that those cooperate with us at the
state level and uh the system that it
was set up Vermont just wouldn't be
practical in New Hampshire
and
so it ended up dying because uh it was
going to take too much work to fix
so we want to make sure we don't want to
put ourselves put the the study
committee in the position of you know
putting together a proposal and not
having it vetted with Des to make sure
it would work with our current systems
um
and solicit industry stakeholder input
on approaches that the manufacturers and
Distributors would best be able to
undertake or facilitate
this is really important we've had some
interest from uh various industry groups
saying we would like to be at the table
for this process and uh because the idea
of extended producer responsibility is
that those those producers take
responsibility we want to make sure that
we in are have them in a discussion so
that they can suggest the ways that they
would best be able to take
responsibility
um
proposed legislation for implementing
approaches that would be readily
adaptable to New Hampshire so that is
you know if it looks like the committee
can put together some draft legislation
or sort of the outlines of draft draft
legislation for something that could be
brought forward uh in the coming year
then that is something that uh the
committee could do it might be that some
of the uh the
um projects that they'd be looking at
would be more complicated than they
could put together given the scope given
the scope and the time and in that case
they could put together they could write
legislation for a further study
committee that would be narrowly
targeted to doing that further type of
legislation so that's that's kind of
what I was thinking about uh one thing
that
um that to keep in mind is that any
study committee will has the power to
essentially
um
control the scope of what they were
studying to the extent that they can
actually get the work done so uh it is
it
the if you say study all epr everywhere
and come up with a comprehensive
Solution that's not going to work in uh
you know in a study committee that's
going to last for two or three weeks two
or three months at the most uh so you
um
so essentially there there needs to be
some mechanism for limiting the scope
but
um the committee itself has a fair
amount of leeway in terms of deciding
what's you know how deeply they're going
to to be getting into any particular
part of it okay representative Bixby I
have a couple comments number one from
the original Bill there is a line line
17 that says the committee May solicit
input from any person or entity the
committee deems relevant to its study I
would like to see that line included in
this okay I I I'd have no objection to
it I I my sense is that that is that
almost goes without saying with study
committees but if you feel more
comfortable with that in there I'd be
happy to put it back in okay thank you
also
um
so my sense from the my feeling from the
original bill was that the charge was
very Broad
and that we needed to be more specific
and I see that you've made an attempt to
to Really hone in on certain aspects of
um what we're putting in our landfills
um you mentioned packaging single-use
Plastics beverage containers electronic
waste batteries automotive waste and
hazardous waste
for me I think that really is a pretty
large
Focus
especially to have a report done by
November 1st and I'm wondering if
there's something we can do to
um maybe
rein that in a little bit
should we as a committee be more
um
you know choose more of a priorities of
of what these items here are listed
maybe we leave off packaging and just
talk about
single-use Plastics beverage containers
electronic waste and I don't know let's
let's pick a couple of these or three or
four of these instead of so many is what
my thought is represent uh thank you
madam chair
um
it was discussed during our hearing that
and I agree with you it's a very broad
scope what we have here and I thought
one of the things that we discussed and
maybe and I thought there was a
consensus is that we would actually look
at materials that were had high toxicity
and go after the most toxic
waste first because really that's what
we're trying to eliminate in our our
landfills is is the toxic waste and
reduce that and I think if we did
something where it talked about the the
toxicity of the waste
um as just opposed to all of it
I'm not saying that none of it this
isn't all of it's not toxic but there's
levels of toxicity in different waste I
mean I'm assuming that batteries are
much more toxic than a single-use
plastic
um so that's where I thought we were
going with this but I could be wrong
representative Bixby
um
so
uh I think uh the one
uh one thing that's a little bit makes
us a little bit more complicated is uh
we are learning that there is
um there's pfas in packaging there is
pfas and single-use Plastics uh and so
uh and and pfas is certainly it's toxic
and we know that it is one of the things
that makes leech leachate problematic uh
which is so
um what might make sense is
um adding uh part of the charge to
um
a set of for the committee to assess the
these in terms of their likelihood of
um of reducing toxicity in landfills and
then uh and then have them focus on
those that will be most effective in
doing that
representative thank you madam chair
just to follow up and I understand about
the pfas and we're all worried about
that and that's something new that has
come about in most recent years but pfas
is in everything it's in the rain that's
dumping that we're getting put on our
land it's in our cosmetics and it's in
the clothing we wear I mean pay fast is
everywhere I mean so to study just pfas
I think you have to be more specific
because it is in everything
whether we like it or not
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I also just want to make sure that
we're making efficient use of our time
there are already limitations on certain
things like battery disposal so I happen
to wonder if those are areas that do
have certain parameters on how they are
disposed of and when you can do a waste
take back day in your communities I
agree that that's an important part of
the discussion but I think there are
already disposal regulations around
those and Under Universal waste so I'm
wondering if that makes sense
to maybe look at some of the other
topics as well representative Howard
thank you madam chair I agree with
representative Murray um that that there
are already
um systems in place and also a lot of
those things have labels on them so fine
you know the resourcing the original
um uh provider is pretty obvious so
um I think that we had talked before
about enhancing alternative packaging or
um and single-use packaging is is
probably a big uh bite to to chew for a
committee
representative germana
thank you madam chair yeah I I would
like to add a third I guess to the
comments of Representatives uh Murray
and Howard and uh and point out that I
think having spoken with some of the
folks at in the landfill in Keene for
example that the the packaging I think
is an important element of this because
of the space you know there are a number
of landfills like the one in Keene that
are starting to run out of space uh and
and that also leads to increased you
know tipping fees you have to then kind
of ship things further away so there are
implications to the uh
overabundance of kind of the packaging
that ends up in landfills as well so I
and I I do agree I think with
representative Murray that I think that
there are significant controls already
around toxic substances and how they're
disposed of so uh from from my
perspective the the packaging element of
this is is important
representative dutzie
uh thank you madam chair
um I've been involved in this for
probably about the last year doing a lot
of webinars I've said this before and
I'm involved with a Plastics working
group for the New Hampshire networks and
I can tell you epr and this whole
Plastics thing uh it's enormous and
trying to to wrap your head around where
you want to focus and what you want to
do is very very difficult for example I
mean if you talk about single-use
plastic okay what are we talking about
because a water bottle is a single-use
plastic okay so so things overlap I
agree with uh chair Aarons that we don't
want to be you know too broad in this
but I think we've reduced it to some of
the issues in in this amendment that you
know are really pertinent and I think
part of the charge of the the committee
is to really grapple with what areas you
know do we focus on because it's it's so
enormous and allowing them this amount
of discretion that's in this amendment I
think it you know is appropriate so that
they might be able to work down and make
recommendations uh if we make it too
narrow then we I think we hamstring them
but I will be the first one to say this
is not going to be easy and that's why I
think we need a committee on it to at
least take the first draft
representative Creighton
yeah and I just like in my head I'm
thinking
why would we not just tell Des they're
the ones with the expertise they're the
ones with the knowledge and the and the
tentacles that go into the different
organizations so I just back it up a
step and you know we've heard numerous
times to limit the number of committees
and study groups and that type of thing
why would we not just say Des take a
look at this
come back to us and and give us a
response representative dutzie
representative Creighton because I don't
the Des does not have the staff and this
issue is something where you really have
to drill down and you really have to do
a lot of research and you have to get a
lot of stakeholders in I mean because
um you know representative Bixby is is
correct I mean we need stakeholders
involved you're really talking about a
lot of time and from what I've seen in
this committee I don't believe that Des
has that ability right now and probably
would see this as a a benefit to them to
be able to help them give some get some
direction very similar to the solid
waste committee that we have going right
now that would be my but you can you can
ask you can ask director wimsat and he
might be able to give you more Direction
okay thanks representative thank you
madam chair have a couple different
questions but one is for representative
dutzy you said you're been working with
a group could you what was that group's
name
uh well uh there is a there is a group
of citizens in New Hampshire it's called
the New Hampshire networks and if I look
at it um a group of very bright
um educated experienced people and if I
kind of think about it in my mind
there's there's a number of different
ways to go at it but they basically
focus on energy and they both focus on
uh waste reduction Plastics so the two
groups that I know they have right now
is they have a styrofoam
um working committee to collect
Styrofoam in the in in the state and
densify it up in Guilford because
there's a densifier at the Guilford
transfer station and then they also have
the Plastics working group where they're
educating people in the towns about
single-use Plastics so it's a big
educational Focus but you know when you
when you start talking about all of the
layers of waste that we have
um you know there's a lot to un unwrap
and the question is what do you focus on
so so it's this is an outside group
non-profit no whatever it's just a group
that's already working in New Hampshire
working on what we're saying we want to
study is that correct kind of
uh no they're they're looking at it more
you know as an educational perspective
so for example when you do your takeout
you know you you call and take out you
bring it home and you're given a plastic
spoon a plastic fork and a plastic knife
which you put in the drawer because
you're going to use your own you know so
they're educating people to say Hey you
know restaurateurs just ask somebody if
they need plastic utensils if they don't
need the plastic utensils then don't
give it to them they're trying to come
up with other ways
um you know to not use single plastic so
so it's more that focused they're
they're not focused
um on I would say the higher level epr
which is what this is it's more on the
user level
okay thank you and one more yes
representative on another topic online
uh five it says here that the study
group will propose legislation for
implementing approaches
um what if the best approach is to have
Des Implement rules and not legislation
why are we limiting it to legislation
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and I just to sort of address both
uh representative Creighton and
representative kompa um since the
Inception of House Bill 617 back in 20
000 uh 2019
um where there was a study committee to
start looking at some of these things
and epr was a concept that came up
during those um study committees
um I think it's important to note that
there were members from Des there
uh who gave their input I would imagine
that a given uh the charge here that is
re-outlined that it would function
similarly they'd have the opportunity to
be a part of that conversation just as
we had the bottle and beverage industry
there we had Hospital Management Systems
there to talk about various aspects of
solid waste so I think drilling down to
that there there's absolutely still a
place for the Department to be a part of
this conversation and should be
um and to your point regarding
rulemaking there are times in which
rulemaking is an appropriate Avenue but
I think
before we get to that point we have to
at least look at
where those appropriate places may be
right but it doesn't have comfortable
you may follow up thank you madam chair
but this year it just says proposed
legislation it doesn't say proposed
legislation or discuss rulemaking uh
that should be implemented it just says
legislation uh and I I would even add
that instead of the language proposed
legislation I might even uh appreciate
suggest possible legislation as language
to to
be put in the amendment representative
Bixby you had your hand up yes I was I
was just going to say that I would be
happy to change that line to okay so you
say suggest possible legislation
uh
or rules or rules
uh okay
I'd be happy to
put that change in sure
um and would that also
be appropriate to say for the next line
propose more specifically targeted study
legislation suggest possible
specifically targeted study legislation
foreign
propose more I would say suggest
possible
um
with director wimsat would you like to
weigh in on uh anything that you've
heard from the committee if the
committee doesn't mind no okay
with regard to a committee suggesting
rules for Des and
anything else that you've heard sure yes
good morning Madam chairman good morning
committee uh for those who don't know me
I'm Mike wimsatta service director of
the waste management division for New
Hampshire Des
um yeah a couple of comments and thank
you for the invitation
um the first thing I would note is that
really
um you know any rulemaking that that Des
embarks on
must be and is
essentially an authority that's
delegated to the agency
somewhat specifically through the
statute so in the case of solid waste
there's some general you know uh well
both both specific in general there's a
section on rulemaking and it in the
statute it directs the agency to make
rules on very specific things and uh
right now to my knowledge we don't have
authority to just you know sort of
unilaterally as an agency decide we
would like to impose epr requirements
for a particular product and then embark
on rulemaking to do that we it would
have to be implemented through a law and
if a statue if they're going to be a
bill that would do that I would Envision
that it would say you know an epr
program for such and such should be
established and then under the
rulemaking section in the statute it
would say yes she'll make rules to set
out the the provisions and structure of
this particular program and these zpr
requirements so I don't think as I
understand I don't think we would be
empowered as an agency unilaterally to
in in embarking rulemaking to in impose
an epr requirement and that's as it
should be I'm not disappointed about
that
um so uh the other other I guess points
I would make is that it's actually
really helpful when committees get
together you know uh representative
Murray who participated on uh you know
the house bill 413 I think it was uh
study committee for solid waste you know
again that committee set a record I
think they had 16 meetings in four weeks
or something like that they were very
energetic it was very helpful I think to
the committee members
um but also to the agency we did
participate we we tried to have someone
at each one of those meetings we
sometimes provided testimony in those
things but but we also listened we
learned an awful lot from the
stakeholders the members and the you
know the solid voice industry uh folks
who you know major sectors that generate
solid ways the hospitals were there
manufacturers were there so it was
really helpful in in and and to be
candid we have a very full plate at DES
for us to unilaterally or orchestrate
something like that and drive that home
would you know
could do it but it would mean that you
know all the the many hours we would
spend organizing that would mean we
weren't doing other things that this
court has asked us to do so there's
always a you know checks and balances
there thank you for that I just have one
question though I know you sit on the
solid waste working group
to what extent will some of this be
covered in in the study from that group
as well
because I don't want to you know have uh
two two bodies doing the same kind of
work sure that's a great question and of
course that group does have a very big
charge and it and it meets over a period
of five years it's already a year in at
this point
um I I I I won't speak for the committee
as a whole I'm a member or the
commission I'm a member of the
commission and I think that you know I
I've heard others say you know it would
be helpful to to have you know that
particular piece someone else looking at
that it doesn't mean that they might not
all because again this committee if this
bill passes and this committee is
created it is work it's work is
ostensibly done by November 1st right
and this commission will go on for you
know another three or four years so the
work that it would do what what it would
learn I think would
feed into and be a great source of
information for that commission to
potentially look further at that because
these things are difficult right and I
understand and you know I I my
sympathies with committee members who
have to learn all this and then to
provide a report by November 1st because
that happens really fast so one
advantage is that if that's the schedule
that it happens on whatever that
committee learns can then feed into the
commission and the commission can do
further analysis and further work with
it thank you
any other comment that you have to offer
no the only other thing I would note is
that um what I think was really powerful
with the 413 committee is that uh the
committee members the group of
legislators really became expert they
learned a lot in a short period of time
and it made them very powerful advocates
for future legislation when they could
share and learning with their colleagues
so I think that you know from that
perspective those that's one benefit the
committee has that that you wouldn't get
is just Des did a study and gave you a
report because you're gonna you're
basically all the work that committee
does those committee members are being
educated okay thank you
any other comments
representative datsey uh yeah I mean
we're talking about if we're talking
about the solid waste working group okay
isn't that chaired by representative
evil yes it is okay and representative
Ebel is a co-sponsor on this bill so by
that I would assume that she probably
you know feels pretty much like what
director wimsat said is that this would
would be additive rather than just
detractive from it okay yeah I sit on
that group too but I just have been to
one meeting because I am a recent
appointee
so uh
um I wasn't sure though you know if they
had this in the works that they're
working on anything so but anyway
uh any other question or comment um
representative Compton did you have a
comment before no okay
uh representative Bixby you have further
so um one thing that I'm wondering is if
uh there needs to be one more line uh in
here that explicitly says that uh the uh
study committee will set priorities for
what they're studying so that
um so that so rather than so rather than
us saying in advance well we're going to
strike out some of the things in section
two we can say that the study committee
will set priorities regarding these from
among these items yeah
of what they will
so I I yeah I agree I mean I think we
can give them the option of studying all
because as it is I really do believe
it's it's a very broad
um
albeit very important uh content here
but I think it is somewhat unrealistic
to think that they would be able to have
a comprehensive report for
all of those items uh coming November
1st so if if we can word this in some
way that they can study existing epr
laws in other U.S and international
jurisdictions regarding
all or some of the
subsequent list
if you catch my drift yeah yeah
Maria yeah I was just gonna say maybe as
um
as outlined by the uh
when we're looking at other us and
international jurisdictions regarding
um the goals outlined before the study
committee maybe that's
okay so yeah if I could make a comment
here I I think if we get if if we agree
in committee on
on the fact that we want to give the
subcommittee the study committee the the
power to
um prioritize and perhaps leave some
stuff out if it doesn't fit uh then we
can figure out the wording of that not
in committee because trying to enter the
documents with 20 people is just crazy
well you're a good worth Smith I think
that uh if for your Amendment you may be
able to come up with the right rewarding
for that representative Murray uh thanks
Madam chair um I would like to not
necessarily push back but ask for
further clarification on the rule making
and Trust to be clear that we do not set
rules either that is something the
department does so I I want to make sure
any other comments questions regarding
okay so um I suppose representative
Bixby you will be working with OLS to
put this amendment together and uh it
was uh
pretty likely we will not be executing
this today but uh we will I would I
would say that it's definite we won't be
exactly because I don't think there's
going to be time to talk to OLS and
actually get them to do something sure
and we don't like to put them under that
kind of pressure for something
absolutely
so I I'm expecting there will be an
amendment brought to the committee next
week when we uh when we set a subsequent
executive and I can circulate a draft uh
before it gets you know set us down okay
any other questions or comments on this
representative partial you would like to
okay
okay then
um seeing no other question or comment
regarding uh the epr study uh bill of HB
253 let us move on to HB 56
and also we can discuss hb602 at the
same time since there's similar bills
um
and those are relative to the permits
for the sighting of new landfills so why
don't we uh kick off our discussion
regarding what we heard from the
hearings as well as how we feel about
both of these bills proposed bills
would anybody like to begin
with a comment questions
representative Murray yep thank you
madam chair and then Betsy uh thank you
very much so um with regard to
um
both of the bills I think that we did
hear some very thoughtful feedback at
the hearing last time that uh
there are some things that we could
potentially have some clarification
around and and with that I also wanted
to just mention that I had distributed
uh at the
hearing an amendment that was number I'm
just wanting to make sure I have that
correct zero six zero nine H I am
working off of an electronic copy but
you all had a paper copy that I
distributed
um last week and so with that I would
like to make sure that the committee
takes that under consideration as we're
sure would you like to uh speak to that
Amendment
all right that's uh
2023-0609h does everyone have a copy of
that yes thank you
um so
the yes the amendment basically further
clarifies
um that pre-existing landfills are are
protected in Statue were grandfathered
in to the um the underlying bill it had
been stated previously
um
so some paragraph there the changes are
in sub paragraphs C and D pretty much
exclusively and it just um some
paragraphs see
um just asked that there any any
landfill that exists that has fully been
permitted that is fully permanent is an
actively accepting wastes is has been
Exempted under that so that is a
clarification it also just continues to
further say that um perennial bodies of
water traversing a footprint even if
they are pre-existing should still be
monitored in accordance in accordance
with or exceeding the US EPA regulations
and guidelines that's the first change
there the second is in uh
in subparagraph D where it does say that
the department May adopt certain rules
under 541a to allow for project
improvements and allowances there are
some thoughts um I don't know how the
committee feels about
um those and I'm happy to bring that up
for discussion but one of the
um those are certain offsets relative to
distance to travel and I'm I'm happy to
uh discuss those there was one other
thing on line 19 that I did want to
notice
um where it talks about hydraulic
conductivity where it says 1 times 10
and it looks like minus five but it's
supposed to be to the negative fifth
power and for whatever reason when
drafting happened that did not translate
that way so I have two other suggestions
for how that could potentially be
written to avoid that looking visually
like that and potentially being
misinterpreted
okay
representative
Bixby
yeah so
um one thing that um
I'm a little bit concerned about is the
uh it seems like the
um allowances that
um the the project project of
improvement allowances are very
um
Loosely defined uh and uh I'm not sure
that uh given how Loosely defined they
are whether that is something that
um Des would be capable would be
comfortable making rule rules about
because it's you know I'm not it's it's
it's I I'm wondering if we if that would
need to be more directive in order for
them to successfully make rules
uh maybe we could get a comment from the
representative Howard
I'm chair um
uh I got a very clear or very strong
message from the Department the Des
Representatives that are hearing that
they thought that this legislation is
premature
and that they were wanted resources or
time to to do their own study and I'm
wondering if
representative Haskins
I'm not sure about an answer to that but
as I went back and looked at the old
bills that did not pass I came to the
conclusion that
the time
for them to have studied this
has not taken place so
I think more time for more study seems
to me to just be kicking the ball down
the road
I think we ought to make a decision
representative
thank you madam chair
um
having been through a lot of these bills
and listening to this for a long time
um
I think that mandating them to study
this through legislation has not been
done in the past and I think that
mandating the study is the way to go my
biggest concern
um with hb602 when when we had that
hearing was that we're putting into
legislation things that Maine has some
of it in legislation and some of it in
rule making and that really concerned me
because if you put everything into
legislation and statute it doesn't leave
any room for anything and as we heard in
testimony Maine was including a lot of
exceptions through the rulemaking
process and I think we need to be very
very careful
from taking another state statute and
rules and adopting it into our statute
we are not Maine our geography is not
Maine I have looked at the geography of
this state can compared to Maine I've
looked at the demographics of the state
compared to Maine it is not comparing
Apples to Apples and I think we need to
representative Knapp
um thank you very much I mean if you had
asked me before this process started
what the setback was for a landfill and
a body of water I think I would have
told you half a mile so I'm appalled
that it's 200 feet in my town I can't
build a deck 200 feet from a body of
water or Wetland so
um you know I think that law has been in
place for 30 years it's too long it's
not enough of a setback and I you know I
agree with representative come to all I
don't think
um HB 602 is really ready for prime time
there's a lot of language in it that
isn't defined we heard that in testimony
and I agree with that point that
um that is a bill that I think needs
more work it it feels like it came
together really quickly and it's just
not ready but I think uh HB 56 is in a
better place I think we have to start
somewhere I mean this has been 30 years
of the same setback and it's not enough
of a protection I don't you know I don't
think you need to be a scientist to say
200 feet it's not enough of a distance
representative thank you madam chair and
representative NAB to your point and I I
know we keep bringing up the 200 foot
setback
but that's only a minimum
it is not what the setback has to be
it's a minimum setback it could be you
could say that the minimum is 200 feet
but Des could come in and tell you that
it has to be a half a mile it's just
setting a minimum
representative Murray ah thank you madam
chair and I think uh to both of the
points that are well made by
Representatives NAB and Cultura
um I I think what we are asking for is
Clarity in the statute to say that
hydrogeologic study has to precede any
sort of setback and so in doing so I
think that is why we are we are asking
for some clarity around this we have
seen that um
this legislation came before us and the
house had a very strong position in a
bipartisan manner uh last legislative
season and I I expect that it's no
different seeing that there are two
members from opposite parties trying to
bring forward language to help clarify
the issue
um I would encourage us to continue to
um I I agree with representative Bixby
that there's perhaps some conversation
around the exceptions or the uh the
allowances that they can maybe be clunky
or cumbersome and I'm happy to work with
you or anybody in the in the committee
uh to make that a little bit more clear
or perhaps maybe remove it
representative Contour thank you and I
believe this is probably a question for
the director
um do we require hydrogeological
whatever that we are asking for
yes thank you for the question and yeah
as has been noted by one of the other
committee members the the 200 foot
setback is the minimum when a new
landfill is proposed to be cited
um there's a requirement to do a a
thorough hydrogeological study and there
are provisions of rule that make it very
clear that
um
the sighting of the landfill needs to
ensure that certain things can be
accomplished one of which is that
surface waters are protected adequately
that
groundwater is protected adequately and
um the landfill once constructed and
operating can be monitored effectively
to ensure that you understand whether
it's performing as designed and then if
it isn't performing is designed that you
have the opportunity to address that and
correct it so
um the short answer your question is yes
there's a thorough hydrogeological
Society that's required prior to
permitting
representative Murray uh yes but thank
you I think to the director's point
though it isn't set in rules is that
correct it's not in statute
the language I just described is is just
is in statute or is in rules that's
correct thank you
so
I I have a question based on testimony
by Nikki delude Roy
from verdantis
and she had stated that
The Five-Year time of travel
consideration included in HB 56
um and
maybe more conservative than necessary
is there a way that perhaps we might
put into this
um HP 56
rather than flatly saying a five-year
distance of travel
to um
because if that's an arbitrary number
and I think that's what we want to try
and get away from is arbitrary numbers
is there a way in which we might want to
reword it to give more flexibility based
on what the hydro hydrological
uh results are
representative Bixby
yeah
um so
the
um one one aspect of that is that um
it is a common argumentative technique
to declare something arbitrary if you
don't like it uh so I'm not uh that the
[Music]
um the idea behind a five-year setback
is that uh in order to uh So currently
Des uh tests roughly every three months
uh and so
um
there could be a three-month delay
before discovering a leak uh so that and
then uh and then when you discover one
there needs to be a set there needs to
be an assessment of you know what is
what is it that we're actually seeing
here that assessment can take time also
then there needs to be
a determination of what needs to be done
in order to prevent it from going
further establish setting up a plan in
order to implement that doing the
implementation those steps can all take
a fair amount of time so the idea it be
between five years with a five-year
setback is that if you have five years
uh of
um of if the distance is going to be
five years between uh when the leak
occurs and when it hits the sensitive
body of water
then you have enough time to discover it
uh
assess it
created a remediation plan and put that
in and start putting that in place uh if
you
if uh you don't have that much time then
you may recognize as a problem and then
whoops it's in the river already
so uh what we so the idea behind having
five years is that it is it it really
gives you the time in order to uh to do
the work and that five years is
determined through hydrogen
hydrogeological assessment of the site
and
it is true that the hydrogeology
may be different between the site and
the sensitive bodies of water so it
might not be exactly five years that you
measure it could be if you measure five
years at based on the if you're if your
estimate is five years based on what is
right near the the landfill
uh there it might in fact actually only
be three years because things might be
more porous as you get closer to the
body of water it could be seven years
but uh if you don't so another aspect of
that five years is that given that you
can't ask you you can't
demand that every landowner between the
proposed site and the body of water
allow you access in order to do a series
of tests on their property in every
direction uh you have to make some
guesses uh and but by making it five
years it gives you enough of a buffer so
that uh you do have the time and it to
to repair something if it
um
uh if that becomes an issue the other
thing is that if you determine if if you
do this as a
very early step in the process than a
company that wants to build a landfill
can look at a perspective site do a
certain number of Geo hydrogeological
assessments and say oh no actually we
can't do this here let's not spend any
more money on it as opposed to getting
way into the process and then realizing
they've spent a whole they've already
sunk a whole lot of money in trying to
make a site work and then discovering
that they can't make it work you don't
want if you're gonna you want to be able
to assess very early on if it's going to
work
representative Contour thank you madam
chair just in reviewing the testimony
from Sanborn head
um and this was in regards to hb602
um they actually said you know
maybe a two-year travel distance and
then allow for rulemaking uh the Des to
adopt new rules based on subjective
criteria
and give them because we know that our
landscape is Ever Changing we know that
our streams and our groundwater is
changing constantly under underneath of
us
um and so maybe a two-year setback and
let them adopt rules
to go up to a five-year setback Maybe
something that would be better I don't
know
um but I do believe that we have never
mandated Des to study this issue and to
look at it and see what they are lacking
in rules we do know that New Hampshire
statute and I could be wrong or is it in
rules that we do require a double liner
for all our our systems now which is a
huge difference in some other states I'm
not sure that in listening to testimony
that Maine even required a double line
or system in their statute where we do
we have been I believe proactive in
addressing these situations we are
proactive in addressing our pfas issues
we have been taking steps in New
Hampshire to mitigate
the contamination we are a tourism state
so I think that it's Des is in vested in
maintaining
that and making sure that we have don't
have incidences in New Hampshire that
would jeopardize that
um and I would just ask the director if
a two-year setback would be better or if
we just allow them to do the study and
get it in you know look at the rules and
see where we're better than other states
and where we're lacking from other
states but I think we need to recognize
that there are differences and why some
states have a five-year setback and they
don't have the double line requirement
of a double liner system
in place and I don't know if they all
have the hydrogeological
testing in place study that has to be
done prior to us citing a landfill and
knowing that a landfill process takes
minimum if I'm correct at least two
years if not longer just to get one
cited
is pretty intense
and so I do believe study is the way to
go but if you could just address the
question about a two-year setback and
thank you representative
um yes I I don't know the answer I don't
know whether five years or four years or
two years is the right number
um I think that you you make the point
that
to date we've not been directed
specifically to announce to analyze and
evaluate this this particular question
um and I think you know there are other
ideas in play in the legislature right
now that would have us do that and we
are we're eager to do that actually we
think that's it's clearly important to a
lot of people that we we do we do an
evaluation like that we do feel like we
need some outside assistance in
reviewing not only our own rules but
those of other states
um and I will note that that yes
um you know the it's easy to look at
another state and just try to compare
apples to apples but in fact may you
know I don't want to throw any shade on
my main colleagues I work with them and
know them and like them a lot
um or their rules but but it is true
that you know that one of the
um things that you can do to reduce the
travel distance in Maine is to put a
double liner in and that for us seems
absurd because we already have a double
liner requirement in our rules so things
are not Apples to Apples and also
um you know the the
um the rules that have been referenced
in Maine do provide a number of
opportunities for variances against all
of these requirements and
um I don't honestly know what the
history is in this in the siding or
expansion of landfills in Maine how
often those variances have been granted
but it's my understanding that our staff
talking with some colleagues in Maine
that that there are a number of
variances that have been issued for
certain requirements so and understand
as well that that the the RSA 149m if
you put specific requirements in the
statute
um
I don't believe there's any specific
provision for waiving you you can't wave
a statutory number basically if you
there may be you could put in Provisions
that say these particular things can be
subject to a waiver we don't use the
term variance but it could be subject to
a waiver and there are Provisions in our
rules for granting waivers but
you need to know that that specific
requirement is subject to or eligible
for a waiver if it's appropriate
representative Bixby
yes so um
I was the the description of the
um waivers or variances I think they're
called project Improvement allowances in
the in the bill but
with respect no sir that's not what I'm
referring to the the the the the
variance is is getting is is a concept
of getting a specific provision of the
rule in their case
um
being able to not observe it not not
being required to comply with it
okay so
um
so if uh which is which is different
from the from what a from a project
Improvement allowance okay
um and uh
so
um
are there as
if
if we wrote this to allow a certain
amount of variance would that give you
the leeway to uh to do that so for
instance uh if we set it at a five-year
distance distance of travel but uh uh
but uh the department has the capacity
to make variances but not reduce it to
say less than two years would that uh
that would that Empower you were to make
appropriate variances it was under the
impression that that is what is
envisioned by this is that right well
you just said the project project allow
the project improvements allowances were
not the same thing as variances so if
I'm so I'm saying if if we made rather
than phrasing it as project Improvement
allowances if we said you had the uh the
capacity to make variances then uh with
I mean I'm not sure how to answer that
question in the department you know we
take the legislature's directives very
seriously and so
um once they're laid down we we do our
very best to craft rules that that are
consistent with those requirements and
then to implement them consistently if
if if General language is saying
you can give a waiver to these
requirements but that's not helpful to
us it's like well what what are the
provisions for granting a waiver what
are the conditions under which a waiver
is appropriate so
um
I mean I guess you know it depends where
we land on this but at the end of the
day if there's a requirement that
there's a five-year time travel distance
setback and that project Improvement
allowances could offset up to of a
certain description could offset up to
two years of that then that could be
implemented without specifically looking
at or considering any waivers if you're
asking
whether it would be helpful for
the department to have the authority to
Grant a waiver to Pro to to provide an
even lesser distance I guess I don't
really understand that because what's
the point in having the requirement if
you if you can offset five to three and
then you can give a waiver to get down
right variance to get down to one I'm
so uh what I'm trying to quite so I
don't I I am not uh fully versed in the
way that rules and variances and uh
project Improvement allowances all are
you know I don't necessarily know how
those work so what I'm trying to do is
figure out
um oh you know how we would need to
write this legislation in order for your
department to find it uh sufficiently
directive but uh possibly also give you
enough uh
uh leeway so that given the specifics of
a project you would be able to make
judgments based on information that we
don't have while we're sitting right
here
I think what I would say is that the
department
feels that a directive to
embark on rulemaking using hydrogeologic
principles and standards of protection
as a description for the guide the
development of those rules that's the
best we think that's the best assignment
for us to do this effectively and uh
would you
if we were to put a specific minimum
time to travel distance in would that be
problematic
again this we don't know you know one of
the things that is is has got the
department concerned about some of these
bills is that the idea of establishing a
specific
travel time distance
without knowing the specifics of
specific sites it's hard to know what
that does to the the prospects of citing
any landfill anywhere that that's really
what it comes down to and we're not
saying that it eliminates all the sites
we just simply don't know and so for us
to come in and say sure impose a
five-year travel distance
we think that would be responsible the
department to say that if that means
that there's actually when you look at
all the other citing criteria that apply
to a landfill if that means that there's
no land anywhere in the state that could
conceivably have a landfill of any size
that that would we think that's
irresponsible for us to testify in that
way on the bill and so what we want to
do is we want to you know that that's
that will be part of our analysis trying
to look at to the extent we can
um try to look at you know what what are
the impacts of setting a specific time
of travel and a distance associated with
that with landfill siding we think
that's part of the analysis but we think
to we're not prepared because we just
don't know to tell you yes it's
appropriate to establish a five-year
time of travel distance or it should be
two years we just don't know the answer
to that
representative
Murray is this further Among Us
um
I just want to make sure that we are
what we're talking about here is
protecting perennial bodies of water so
we are asking for rivers and streams and
Coastal Waters to be protected with that
time to travel five-year setback in the
event that there is a failure if not
if when as as noted in the US EPA that
landfills liners do leak over time so I
I I I maintain that uh The house's
position this year is no different from
two years ago in the sense that we felt
very strongly that protecting our
perennial bodies of water in a
measurable way that used science first
was the way we needed to be proceeding
to make sure that landfill citing was
done in a way that protected those
perennial bodies of water
representative coulon
thank you madam chair
um I think of the two bills HB 56 is the
stronger one but I have a question
regarding the long-term goal of
legislation like this we've heard in
testimony that Massachusetts Connecticut
and Vermont have placed moratoriums on
permitting landfills and I'm just
wondering possibly to you uh
representative Mari what is the
long-term goal of legislation like this
thank you madam chair May answer the
question okay thank
you um so
so to your point representative coulon I
this is not stating that we should be
setting a moratorium though I hear of
you with what you're saying with respect
to our neighbors I what we are seeking
to do here is protect water right
because once once our water is is
contaminated that's it we don't it takes
an extreme amount I appreciate that
there are methods to clean it up we'd
prefer not to have to go there in the
first place
foreign
Howard
um this is a question for representative
Murray um is this is this bill uh
limited only to protecting water because
one of the things that I liked about 602
was that it also protects residents why
um uh having limitations about how near
it can be to be a public roads property
boundaries and Residences
thank you representative Murray you may
respond thank you madam chair
um
to your point representative Howard I I
I can't speak for the representative in
602 but I I understand that there are
other areas as well that you you find
appreciable in the language around other
types of uh you know roads and uh but
with respect to 56 if we could have that
dialogue and I I'm just curious as to
what
what you find appealing about those
things I I know that those were set
forth in maybe some rule making in other
states and so I'm curious
um there aren't a whole lot of
definitions either so we I think that
that was something we heard in testimony
that we were seeking further
clarification on like what unstable
soils meant or like those types of
things
a follow-up show
um I think I it's actually explicit in
the the bill that we were given on 602
that uh that these are were specific
setbacks they had you know footage uh
set back and I I guess
um I guess I could just have a yes or no
question should we be considering
um impact on humans on residents as much
as we are on the water
representative Murray you may respond
yeah
I'm sorry no look I there are certain
water is a human health concern having
potable drinkable water I also know that
when there are certain uh
when landfills are cited or any anything
else is cited there are many instances
in which uh there are other types of of
zoning regulation or laws that have to
be put in place around those other types
of things like roads and bridges and
easements for power line traversing and
things like that so there's a lot that
goes into it and I so I'm I I hear you
on what you're saying um
representative germana thank you very
much Madam chair are there a couple of
points thinking about the testimony and
some some excellent points been raised
by uh folks on the committee that I'd
like to address one is that the when we
talk about the liners and we have the
double liner system I agree with many of
the points that representative has made
I would however point out that uh
talking about the whether we have
one-liners or two as opposed to the the
time uh that it would take
um a spill or seepage to get to a water
source they're not exactly the same
thing right the purpose of the liner is
to prevent the leak we're talking about
once a leak has occurred right so the
double liner means a leak is less likely
but it doesn't necessarily have an
impact on the setback distance once a
leak has occurred the other point that I
would make regarding the relationship
between whether it's a minimum of 200
feet again I appreciate that
clarification
ultimately distance is a function of
time
right the reason why we establish at
least 200 feet
is to say that our expectation is that
giving us that setback means that we
have time to react once a leak happens
so in that case distance as far as I'm
concerned is merely a measure of time
and so what we should really be
concerned about here in in determining
its statute and Rule is time how much
time do we have from the time a leak
occurs to the time it reaches a body of
water in distance in this case which
we've had in statute for 30 years is
simply a substitute for time as far as I
can tell so I think time however we
determine that appropriate time is the
appropriate measurement for how far a
setback should be thank you
yes ma'am sure just just a couple of
thoughts and and first of all I agree
completely that the intent intention of
this discussion is is absolutely On
Target
which is how do we
um protect our Waters
um but listening to to testimony
today and uh and last week from some
folks that are much more qualified than
my 40 year old environmental engineering
degree
um I think that that the velocity is
also part of that so it's not just
distance and time it's
the soil analysis and how fat and how
fast it moves through
and I think that that anything that we
look at that sets a standard
uh
in terms of time distance
in statute I think is premature
uh I would much rather have someone with
much more experience than than I've got
make that determination recognize it
well I'm sorry one recognizing that for
each site the soil the amount of water
the movement is completely different
um and so I I guess in in representative
Murray and I talked about it this
morning
um the the one thing that that she said
not that it's the only thing but the one
thing she said is one that really
resonated with me is
um okay put a moratorium of two years
say don't do this until we really sort
ourselves out and figure out what the
right way to do it is but I I do think
that as the testimony this morning with
it that they're interested in figuring
that out and that What legislation we've
got should
enable them to do that and and put an
accountability forcing function into
that and I'm sorry I got more hands
after what I said before we started it's
not on the bus help or not
representative dutzie
yes thank you madam chair
um in reviewing
um the testimony that we received uh at
the last public hearing one of the
things that uh cropped up with me is
that it basically is
um you know one side uh it's the expert
testimony that you would see
um at a jury trial so for every
hydrogeologist that says this is
arbitrary you have another
hydrogeologist and I will just quote
from this H uh House Bill 56 addresses
the current completely inadequate
arbitrary and potentially dangerous
landfill set-back criteria of 200 feet
from surface water in two very important
Hydro geological ways and this is from a
hydrogeologist so you know one two
points that I want to make first of all
the bill that we have before us was
worked and reworked and reworked by many
people who are hydrogeologists and this
is what they came up with
you know so I don't want people to think
that this bill was just taken out of
thin air I mean we all real all remember
how how hard representative Tucker
worked to get a bill that could be
passed it was also my understanding that
we had buy-in on that bill from New
Hampshire des
and the house and the Senate okay we
didn't have it from from the governor so
I think we need to take that in
consideration I don't see how
kicking this can down the road and
having a study done by one
hydrogeologist is going to rectify the
issue that we have I think the situation
is is apparently either the science is
not there or the scientists cannot agree
on the science that is there so doing a
study by one company that is chosen
through an RFP by the New Hampshire Des
is I don't think I mean you'll get an
answer but I don't know if you're going
to get the right answer because we can't
even come up with the right answer here
representative Contour you had your hand
up I did Madam chair and thank you very
much
so I'm going to make a statement and Des
can correct me if I'm wrong but I do
believe that
every city town and municipality in the
state of New Hampshire with the
exception of one has a body of water in
it
representative Bixby
yes um
I'd like to make a comment about uh what
bill we are considering or what bills
we're considering today and what is out
there so
we heard Reference last week that there
is a bill that is coming through the
Senate that is proposing a study
committee or is proposing that a method
of study uh that Des would undertake
with a um with a contractor
and that is a Senate bill
and uh it is uh it was recommended
positively out of committee there it is
likely that we'll we will be seeing that
at some point over crossover we can make
our assessment about that study can that
study bill to when the Senate Bill comes
to us uh as the as a Senate bill that we
are doing the the second pass on uh so
what we have before us is two house
bills both of which use the basic idea
of determining a time to travel
measurement uh distance to travel
measurement which would give us a
certain amount of uh give a give a
certain amount of land of time buffer
around the landfill uh should there be a
spill and uh so there are some uh
differences between the two bills that
we have before us one of them relies
very heavily on on the rules from the
state of Maine and uh there are um
as was pointed out in testimony uh there
are some definitions that are absent
from it that might be necessary in order
to make it workable uh and uh it is also
um
it was it is construct that the the main
rules that is based on are constructed
within Maine statute and that is
something that is not necessarily
um parallel or
um or uh
it doesn't necessarily work in the same
way that New Hampshire statute does so
uh
putting main rules in New Hampshire
statute could create conflicts that are
that we we can't see without looking at
the whole body of main law and the whole
body of New Hampshire law right now uh
so I would suggest that uh that uh are
focused mostly be on HB 56 and
we determine whether or not uh a is an
approach that is
appropriate for us to use right now uh
and B whether there are further
amendments that need to be made Beyond
uh the amendment that representative
Murray brought to us which I think uh
especially in terms of the grandfather
section I think is really critical
representative Bixby would you suggest
then that um
hb602bitled and that we further work on
HB 56 for an amendment for next week I
would actually propose that we retain
602 because I think that uh we're not
it's not clear what's going to happen
down the road and we might need that as
a vehicle for further legislation it
costs nothing for us to retain it at
this point and then if we need it in the
fall we we can use it if we don't need
it in the fall we can then recommend itl
any other thoughts on that from our
committee representative
representative NAB
um I just wanted to agree with
representative Bixby and to
representative Howard's point I think
that 602 probably had some numbers in it
that were valid and came from someplace
but I don't think that the people who
were testifying on behalf of that Bill
had the answers to it so I I'm curious
as to where the numbers came from and so
I just think it'll be it would be nice
to have
um retained so that if we decide that
there needs to be more protection for a
Landover landowner nearby or around
roads we could further investigate that
representative
thank you madam chair
um I'm actually in favor of italing 602
I don't believe that we will have the
time
to look at what parts of 602 are in
statute and which part of the minimum
rules and how they uh conflict with New
Hampshire law
and I believe that if I know that there
may be other bills coming from the
somewhere else that could be retained I
any other comments on
representative Bixby
yeah so uh one of the things about or
um actually any bill that comes to us is
that we have the capacity to change it
substantially we don't need other than
the fact that the topic of the bill is
solid is landfill citing
we have a broad authority to put
whatever we want in there in play in
including replacing the entire Bill uh
and uh so
by saying that we're keeping it as a
vehicle I'm not suggesting that we net
we actually keep any of the the content
of it beyond the fact that it's about
Wentzville Society
okay thank you
um
I did have
there was there was a a line in hb602
which I thought was
um something that I wanted to discuss
with the committee uh possibly adding
that into
um HB 56 and that is on page two which
line three that says the area within the
solid waste boundary shall not lie over
or be within 300 feet of a significant
Sand and Gravel aquifier
um aquifer what what are people's
thoughts on that particular
issue
representative Murray
um I wouldn't be opposed to I mean when
we're looking at um
the fact that aquifers are diff I mean
aquifers are below ground whereas what
we were talking about is perennial
bodies of water through groundwater
um flow I wouldn't be opposed to that I
would also say that I thought that um
one of the other Lines within the bill
that had some Merit was talking about
um wildlife habitat areas
um so those were the two areas that I
thought were
um of note
okay thank you representative Bixby
yeah so um I would agree that that it
makes sense to make sure that we don't
put a landfill on top of a or or close
to sand and gravel aquifer I'd like to
direct a question to director wimsat as
to whether there is currently any
Prohibition in state law in terms of
putting a landfill
citing a landfill within that distance
of a
aquifer
so thank you for the question
representative Bixby yes um there there
are Provisions in the law or in rule
that that um
limit the sighting of a landfill over
and and I apologize I don't have the
specific site so I'm not going to try to
describe it with Precision but basically
for a significant
um aquifer and drinking water source
there are specific setbacks um or
specific Provisions that that limit
citing a landfill you know within a
certain distance of that or or really I
don't even know that it's a numerical
distance it's probably more and I will
get this for you but I think it's more
General language about that it can't
have an impact on a significant I'm
drinking water aquifer
okay so uh
would a so would all sand and gravel
aquifers be considered drinking water
Aqua first
it it doesn't no the the answer is no
it's a specific
um
level of or a significance of a
particular aquifer keep in mind that
there are sand and gravel deposits
nearly everywhere in New Hampshire or
varying degrees in size and any one of
them is is very likely capable of
providing adequate water for a residence
or something like that it's always a
question of yield and sustainability you
know so all aquifers are clearly not
created equal and it's one of the
frustrations that geologists have in New
Hampshire when people talk about oh well
that's over an aquifer and of course the
reality is almost everything in New
Hampshire all the overburdened deposits
are or could be described as an aquifer
it's just a question of how much water
and of what quality and what what
capacity and yield could that aquifer
provide drinking water
so um but but there is currently in in
law or in rules
um a Prohibition of essentially putting
a uh landfill over an aquifer right
again what I will be happy to do if it's
helpful is I will get an answer in more
or less real time here about what the
what the rule actually says I just don't
have a memory I think maybe someone back
here has it
sure I was going to ask if and you are
as you were talking I just sort of
looked up the existing rules and I'd
like to read to the committee if I may
this is from
envsw802 groundwater protection
standards it's a subsection of the
citing rules as they exist today
subsection a reads a landfill shall not
be cited within the Wellhead protection
area of a community or non-community
non-transient water supply well system
as delineated in the department Source
water protection area inventory
subsection
um
C reads identification of the areas
cited above shall be based on a
hydrogeologic investigation which
provides all site-specific information
required to model the pre-construction
and post-construction groundwater and
surface water regimen
as a hydrogeologist those are the two
sections I'd refer to in terms of
specifically applying to what would be
sand and gravel or water supply well
aquifers and I'll defer back to the
commissioner for the rest of the context
but I'll stay here in case you need
another section thank you for that I
appreciate that clarification for the
committee
foreign
so so representative Bixby um So based
on that
um I'm not sure that uh that it would be
necessary for us to put that uh
specific
um language into this bill but what's
your feeling on that no I agree
um but then that leads me to some
concern though
since we as a committee are not familiar
with what all of the rules are
indeed what Des the rules are that they
operate Within
it it brings me some hesitation as to
our
um
in the in the bill that we are looking
at now with HB 56 because are there some
aspects of this bill that
um supersede or interfere with what we
I mean I I am cognizant of uh our
concern over the minimum 200 foot
setback
I'm not a fan of that at all
um but I'm not familiar with what the
rest of the rules are that Des uses in
citing landfills
representative Bixby yes so I think that
um one of the things that so the in
terms of the
um
levels of uh priority so essentially we
as legislators deal with statute which
sets out the principles that we want to
be enacted we don't need to look at
every single uh you know detail of how
those are are enacted but
um I I look at the idea of
requiring a uh sufficient time to deal
with a leak or a spill as being a matter
of principle
and uh in terms and that is something
that would make sense for us to say okay
this is something that needs to be taken
into account whenever you're making
rules you can't you can't allow a
permitting if there is not this
um this distance the safety distance
that is determined by hydrogeology and
uh by calculation uh and so I I see that
as a matter of principle uh in terms of
um
how that affects the other rules uh if
there are rules that are not sufficient
to meet that well that's a principle
we've laid out and the rules need to be
adjusted if there are if there are rules
if the rules meet that then good
Point well taken
representative Murray thank you madam
chair I you know I I do uh to piggyback
on what representative Bixby had
mentioned I I want to make sure that
we're we're considering
the vision and the intent like
representative Bixby said we have seen
before this committee several instances
and where like just like Coakley
landfill for example that is a super fun
site that has has has complexities and
problems now that have existed and are
still in the cleanup process and it
hasn't been fully completed I never want
to get there again and I think that by
having Clarity in what we are asking for
here is a step in the right direction to
put this in statute
representative Howard thank you madam
chair in in
um to sort of piggyback on what you said
about the aquifier
um this may reflect an incomplete
understanding of the rule how
legislature affects rules but um it
seems like this uh um legislation
changes rules it seems from what I
understand it seems like the the Des is
going to be looking sort of creating a
new set of rules in response to this uh
this bill this legislation and um if we
if they are taking a new look shouldn't
they also be looking at the aquifier
shouldn't we put a trigger in there that
they include amplifiers in their new set
of rules even if they already have
any other comments representative Bixby
uh so our rulemaking is
um a fairly complex and time-consuming
operation
and uh
so I I don't want to uh just have a
handful of things that we say Des needs
to look at rules on this this and this I
if unless they are
um
uh unless there is clear evidence that
it is not being taken to an into an
account right now uh the with with the
distance uh with the setback distance
uh the fact that there's a minimum of
200 feet uh says that that's something
that is that does not conform with our
principle that there needs to be uh
enough time to deal with it
um but in terms of the uh the aqua
citing related to aquifers it sounds
like there is currently an appropriate
an appropriate approach in uh rules uh
to deal with aquifers now uh the uh
there is the Senate bill which we'll be
able to look at later that is suggesting
a study it might be a good idea to just
do a study an overall study of the rules
as well as having a specific principle
of how much time you need to in order to
respond but
um and that and that might be a place to
look at uh these other things but I
think that in terms of focus the focus
of this bill we really need to just
focus focus on that setback distance
representative thank you madam chair
so in listening to the testimony and
understanding The Five-Year setback
that's in this bill
and listening to the director and Des
if we implement this bill we're tying
their hands and we're putting in statute
this five-year setback that when we have
if we they go on to have the study done
their hands are tied
it's done
I mean we would have to undo legislation
in order for them to make the best
recommendations if this is not
appropriate
and my question is is we don't know what
is appropriate we are saying that a
five-year setback is appropriate if we
pass this bill but nobody knows nobody
can answer that question honestly in the
state of New Hampshire we have had
differing views some say yes some say no
and until we get an assessment and a
study an in-depth study to study this
issue
I think that proposing any legislation
representative Dotsy
it's my understanding that we already
have legislation in place
which many hydrogeologists feel is
arbitrary and not based on scientific
evidence we also have in our manual a
letter dated February 21st from the New
Hampshire Des Robert Scott commissioner
which you know I look at some of the
concerns that he has I mean there seems
to be three major concerns that that he
has one you know states that the travel
time is arbitrary well the 200 minimum
setback is is arbitrary none of them are
you know seem to be deal breakers in my
opinion if New Hampshire Des really had
major concerns about this bill then why
do we only have one sheet of paper
from the director from the the
commissioner of the agency
looking at the bill and I will say again
involved in this legislation and I think
we are trying everything that we do with
this will be arbitrary it's already
arbitrary okay should we wait another
two years and allow these arbitrary
rules that are in place now to dictate
uh where we cite landfills I mean I
think we have to think about this
representative germanna thank you madam
chair I'd like to concur with
representative uh dutzie and that we
have I like the analogy of you know if
we were in a courtroom and we had expert
Witnesses and we have expert Witnesses
telling us one thing and then we have
another set of expert Witnesses telling
us something else and if we conduct this
study uh that we're talking about the
possibility of then we have another set
of expert Witnesses and their testimony
may be
in conflict with some of the other
evidence that we've heard right in which
case we say well which of these sets of
experts are we going to listen to I
think that the The Five-Year setback is
a statement on behalf of the house about
how much time we think at a minimum is
important for us to be able to
prevent
the possibility of a significant source
of pollution in our water system so I I
don't see the idea of having another
study with another set of
hydrogeologists is somehow it's going to
be
um the definitive answer any more than
the testimony that we've heard so far in
the five-year period as I said is a
statement about our commitment to making
sure that it doesn't happen in the
future thank you representative Haskins
out of respect for all the work that's
gone into this bill
and with reference to representative
Dusty's comments if I'm going to get a
vote and make a decision I'm going to
err on the side of protection not the
other side
representative NAB
I took in car with thank you to concur
with representative Haskins I mean you
have to look at the consequences here
the consequences we heard a lot of
testimony about monitoring and
mitigation but when the cat's out of the
bag it's out of the bag when the pfas is
leaked when these chemicals have leaked
you can't just put them back the
mediation remediation doesn't you know
it's if you've ever been involved in
remediation it's a tremendous amount of
work we have pfas in our town you can't
just get rid of the pfas you can't just
put it back in the flame retardant it's
very very arduous and expensive to do
cleanup so knowing that you've had a
leak only tells you that you've had a
leak you know it doesn't protect the
water it doesn't stop the leak you just
have that information so I I feel like
the consequences to a leak are so high
that the bar to protection has to be
equally high so thank you representative
Murray thank you Venom Taran I think
that the uh one point that we might in
addition to the public health concerns
and the public safety concerns I I think
it's incumbent upon us to not forget
that um we have a large tourism industry
of folks who rely on outdoor recreation
and they come to New Hampshire to enjoy
the outdoors particularly in in
communities all across from the Seacoast
to the up north
um and I want to make sure that we are
keeping New Hampshire as pristine as
possible to make sure that we have the
ability to continue to attract folks to
come here and play here and want to stay
here and I think that that's important
representative Creighton
yes I I'm I agree with everything you're
saying that just another take on it
uh any landfill that's in the state
today is in the state
there are no landfills being considered
as as perted testimony
so by saying
put it put it to your moratorium on it
don't rush to failure
figure out we'll figure out what the
right answer is we're not making
anything worse
there's no landfill going in we put a
moratorium on it and you're not making
it any worse you're not creating
anything new
all you're doing is continuing to clean
up whatever we screwed up already and
then figuring out how the new stuff goes
in in a more appropriate way so that it
prevents those things that you're
talking about
that's sort of my my take on it
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um
to your point you know I don't I think
representative Bixby said that you know
I think that what we were discussing is
that there is something in works on the
other side of the body that's coming
through that make makes mention to this
uh
potential
uh yeah and so to that end you know
I don't know that it
either one has to supersede one another
I think our responsibility here in the
house is to make sure that we are
continuing to do our uh what we were
charged to do and this is a response to
representative vote
thank you madam chair
um I think everything that's been said
here is absolutely valid but I want to
back up what representative Haskins has
said very specifically and I can tell
you when I go for my morning Jog and
when I go downtown Portsmouth for my
morning coffee
so many residents and people within my
district say what is being done about
pfas what is being done about the issues
that we have continually discussed as a
community
and continually as a state and it and it
kind of pulls at me every single time
when I have to look at them and say
nothing or we're we're going through
these different processes in order to
determine what the best steps are
the people of New Hampshire and the
people specifically on the Seacoast that
I talk to are looking for answers
they're looking for us to take those
next steps to say what mitigation
methods and which ways are you going
about to solve these issues
and it's hard when I'm sitting there
with my mocha and every time I'm trying
to tell our residents you know well
we're still in the process of doing that
or I don't have answers for you
so I think now is the time to take those
steps forward to put the protections
into place and to finally say and have
our opportunity to go back to our
constituents and say we're taking the
necessary steps we're doing what you
have asked us to do it's time to protect
representative Davis
thank you madam chair I I agree with
representative Murray but I'm just
curious if we do put a two-year
moratorium on this
what what do we do with that trash in
between then I know Cadbury has a very
specific plan that that cannot take it
uh I don't know about Rochester I can't
speak for them but I'm just wondering
representing Bixby
yeah so
um
so both
um both throughout TurnKey in Rochester
and uh Mount carvery have
um permitted capacity well into the next
decade uh and so uh the there's not a
there's not a need right the with the
two-year moratorium uh there is still
time to
um to you know deal with the future of
trash in the State uh but a two-year
moratorium is part of another bill
that's coming to us later uh we can do
which if we pass HB 56
it doesn't prevent us from passing the
other bill as well with that moratorium
but one of the things that I think is
really important uh is that uh
whether you know no matter what the even
if we end up having a moratorium and a
study I think we still need to lay out
the principle that there needs to be
time to deal with uh a leak or a spill
that could threaten nearby water bodies
and that principle is something that uh
I I think needs to be in place
no matter what so uh the uh the study
might yield other things that need to be
uh dealt with in order to improve our
methods if we get around to doing that
study but I think that having a
clear
uh time buffer between disaster and the
resp and our ability to complete a
response to it is really critical
to your statement representative Bixby
so then
is it your opinion
that five years is an appropriate time
versus some other amount of time three
years four years
uh and yes I think that five years is I
a uh if we look at other states that
have that you know Maine has six
um I think New Jersey has 12 uh but uh I
think that five is a safe minimum uh and
uh
a safe minimum without any further
um
uh steps Beyond what's currently in rule
uh I think that uh the
um
the what we what the Senate gave us last
year in terms of having project
Improvement allowances uh being able to
reduce that I think that is a place
where uh the study might be appropriate
might appropriately suggest what those
Improvement allowances should be but uh
I think that in terms of a principle we
need to have
enough time to react so
given that I mean if we if and I don't
want to talk about the Senate bill as
much but I'll tell you
if if we pass this with a five-year
setback
for want you know water to be traveling
underground or leachate to be traveling
Underground
and
we then also did Embark upon some study
whereby
um
they came out with some other
recommendations
I suppose that we could go back and
amend this five years to be something
that makes more sense based on
studies that are done
would that be that a consideration
that's entirely correct if if the study
if if a study in the future comes back
and says you know we need that it makes
sense to alter this in a certain way uh
we as the legislature have the power to
um to adjust that I mean we've there are
several of our bills in this committee
earlier have been adjusting things that
were in previous statute that no longer
work and uh that is a that's a constant
process if uh if the if a department
comes back to us and says
um we have you know in the process of
rulemaking we discovered this is it
needs needs to be altered then we have
the power to do that
well you know so just my concern is with
going back to what director wimsat said
was that you know the law is the law and
that's what they have to follow
and if the law is not
um
benefiting Us in any way uh it can it
can go the other way and be you know a
problem
right so I think that uh
this gets back to that idea of principle
the principle is that we need time to
there needs to be time for re
remediation if there's a if there's a
disaster and uh the five-year uh amount
of time is something that was suggested
by someone who has been in uh uh in
Federal Regulation for a very long time
and has dealt with a a number of
instances where uh rules weren't
sufficient to uh to to carry the full
weight and need it and there needed to
be statutory back up in order to make
sure that those uh that the rules uh
really met the needs of uh of
environmental remediation so uh it's
it's not a number that's picked sort of
out of thin air it's a number that's
that was picked by someone who is has
experience in the field who knows what
the procedures are for remediation and
knows that it's not an immediate process
okay representative coulon you had your
thank you madam chair I'm uh
yeah just one point that I wanted to
make again to the long-term impacts of
the things that we're doing here today I
live in a rural area we do not have a
transfer station where we live if we
make it hard to access Waste Services
they're not going to go into a landfold
they're going to go directly in a water
source the end of a dead end Road
there's going to be no pond liner
there's going to be no
hydrogeological survey or anything like
that so I want people to just kind of
consider the long-term impacts of the
things that we're doing and I think it's
important uh long term to realize that
New Hampshire needs to have waste
Independence we can't be kicking the can
down the road like the other states that
we've considered here like Connecticut
Vermont and Massachusetts thank you
representative datsey
um yeah I just want to refer us to some
testimony that we received last time and
basically this was a study and it says
uh I hope the committee realizes that
all HB 56 would do is make it slightly
harder to cite a new landfill in the
minority of grossly inappropriate sites
that should not even be considered and
then they have a chart here which which
shows that mount Carberry it would take
under HB 56 it would take
106 years to travel one mile uh TurnKey
it would be nine years
Bethlehem depending on how you do it it
could be 14 years but the bottom line is
is that please also be aware that the
majority of the landfills that New
Hampshire relies on today would likely
have passed the HB 56 test and I think
we have to keep that into into
consideration we're not asking for
anything
you know that is I think out of you know
out of the purview of what best
representative datsey given your comment
it almost then sounds that the current
Des
rules for citing landfills have worked
because
if in it if you're saying that and if
this testimony from Mr Finkel says that
the majority of landfills in that New
Hampshire relies on today would likely
have passed the HB 56 test based on
these the criteria
then but it also says that the proposed
Granite State landfill
okay would reach the one mile uh test in
330 days true but that hasn't been
permitted and that has not been cited so
well you know right but just saying yeah
representative Compton
thank you madam chair
and
listening to the testimony it almost
sounds like we're putting the card
before the horse
currently you're we're talking about
there's already a moratorium
we're talking about a study
if there's already a moratorium why is
there a need to rush to legislation
okay there is not there is no moratorium
no okay just wanted to ask that question
just clarifying that okay thank you
because it was stated then today
representative germana
thank you madam chair uh and if I could
uh in in response to your
good question about right you know is it
necessary given the testimony that
representative dutsy referred to I'd say
that the key word to me in that
statement is majority right and it only
takes one or two uh leaks and problems
for us to to have a major problem so it
may be true that a majority of current
landfills would have would have met this
uh these requirements anyway majority I
think there's a key word I also want to
reiterate that I think that talking
about time
of travel to a water source is something
is a principle that that we should stand
on it makes a lot more sense to me uh
than distance again I I can maintain the
distance is is a function of time uh but
I don't know if it is uh if perhaps a
director knows the answer to this
question or anybody on the committee
about how the 200 feet was was
determined because we got into this back
and forth about what's arbitrary what's
not arbitrary I think that we all assume
based on our work and the testimony we
hear from witnesses that these are not
arbitrary numbers they are based upon
testimony for example The Five-Year
setback but I'm wondering what the 200
feet is based on because in the end it's
this Committee in this house they're
committing to a principle right upon
which then rules are are based so I'm
wondering if that 200 feet what the
specific scientific evidence was that
concluded that uh a minimum of 200 feet
was the appropriate setback minimum ah
thank you representative Romana I don't
know the source of the 200 feet I I
would point out again that it's a
minimum that it's really not it's part
of a larger
um
system that determines what this how
landfills are going to be cited and in
in practice
um I believe there may be some examples
of I mean I'll give you an example there
was a a setback issue
um at the at one of our the other
landfills that
um
was the problem and they actually got a
variance from it it was a small Wetland
area that didn't meet the setback
the company was within their rights and
would have likely gotten a permit to
fill the will and the Wetland and
basically
um you know then they would have meant
the setback because the surface water
would have been gone but they actually
got a a a a waiver from that requirement
because they could they had a system
where they could actually allow it to uh
to to not not fill it but basically
allow it to continue and it actually
made a lot of sense in the particular in
that particular construction project so
the the examples of the 200 foot setback
really tend to be very small Wetland
areas around
and there aren't very many of those
examples either but in terms of large
you know what we would think of a
significant surface water a pond or a
lake or a river the setbacks are
typically much greater not as a result
of that 200 foot requirement but as a
result of the larger
um or the the broader language about
protection of surface water quality and
making sure that we can in many cases it
has to do with just being able to
adequately Monitor and detect a a leak
and and deal with that I'm in a
reasonable amount so so the 200 foot
um really is just serving as a minimum I
don't know I honestly don't know where
it came from originally it's been that
in the rules for some time may I follow
up better sure you may thank you uh and
so if if it definitely makes sense to me
that in most cases is greater than 200
feet but if you determine it should be
more than 200 feet my thinking is that
what informs that decision is how long
it would take for a leak to get to a
body of water that we're trying to
protect which brings me back to my point
that the underlying measure here
ultimately is time that it would take
pollutant to get from a landfill to a
body of water that we're concerned about
sure I don't disagree with that at all I
think time is is the key factor and I
think that if you look at if you were to
survey the decisions we've made and the
about siding and the and the the permits
we've issued or denied that basically
that analysis with respect to surface
water is about ensuring that that broad
language is satisfied which is to say
that the sighting in the op construction
and operation in the landfill will not
pose an adverse uh you know an excessive
risk to the quality of that surface
water and that we'll be able to Monitor
and ensure that that surface water is is
protected I would also note that you
know in terms of distance and such
um
while we may have surface waters around
our landfills at varying distances in
almost every case or in every case there
is groundwater
immediately there it's right there right
and so our Focus over time is really
about protecting groundwater quality and
that's why the ground or monitoring
networks we put around landfills have
the initial Wells very closely spaced to
the liner system and we monitor those
very carefully and those become our
initial Sentinel to determine whether
there's something going on and so as a
result I think essentially almost by
default if you will not to say that it
requires a default but
the surface water gets protected because
we're looking at the immediately
adjacent groundwater so carefully and
closely and routinely that if there is
an issue we're going to identify and be
able to address it thank you sir thank
you madam chair
representative Murray
and we are just about ready to wrap up
so I think we've kind of talked this out
sure I I just wanted to make a rep a
real quick point with regard to coulon's
point on landfill capacity and that's
part of the reason that uh in the
amendment I was clear to make sure that
we included
um
clearer language for pre-existing
landfills that have the ability to
expand that are already grandfailed
grandfathered in there I agree with you
we don't want folks disposing of their
items somewhere else
um but to that end I just wanted to make
that point that I felt like that was
there
thank you
um so
again I don't believe this this bill
will be exact out today we have uh
certainly some work that needs to be
done on this and I believe an amendment
would be forthcoming
um so we'll likely consider
continue this discussion next week
with that I am going to adjourn and
break for lunch
um and see uh Republican caucus back
here at one o'clock
where we will discuss uh
various matters and uh Democrats will be
meeting uh in room 403 upstairs uh at
yeah I if you might we do have an
amendment to hb119 that we will be
considering during our exec session so
um our
committee researcher is passing that out
to you so you can become familiar with
it
taking out the threshold yeah
foreign
okay good afternoon everyone welcome
and we are going to get started on our
exec session
I will start off uh asking the clerk to
Madam chair
here
representative Creighton
president represent here representative
Dolan yeah representative Davis Arnold
representative brouillyard
represent coulon
representative Kenny
representative smart
represent Bixby here
representative dutse
representative Murray
representative here represent Haskins
here representative Howard
representative NAB
representative Davis Fred
thank you madam Clerk and open up the
exec session for HB 231 and I'm looking
for a motion from representative
Creighton
you guys Madam chair I move HB 231 in
expedient to legislate
do I hear a second
second
thank you representative Davis uh
representative Creighton would you like
to please speak to your motion all right
yes ma'am uh although I I agree that the
declawing of cats for
personal
um reasons and not medical reasons is is
a terrible thing to do
I do believe
[Music]
that first of all it's not a problem in
New Hampshire testimony indicated there
wasn't a problem New Hampshire and it
was very rarely done second is that
most veterinarians in New Hampshire and
and don't do it and advise people on
other options to create the same effect
um the other thing is that
um
I believe that uh that that procedure
should be
um
a discussion between the veterinarian
and the owner rather than directed at
the from the state level I think that uh
that's the type of law that uh we do not
need to do is direct that type of thing
from the state level but rather leave it
to the doctors and the owners to figure
out
over thank you
representative germana thank you madam
chair uh I speak in uh in favor of
passing of uh OTP for uh H Bill 231 when
we heard testimony I found compelling
arguments on both sides not really
knowing which way to go uh as committee
members know I reached out to our local
vet to receive her uh feedback I was
moved and and
influenced by her letter which I
circulated to members of of the
committee uh she said that she sees it
as largely a generational thing among
vets she said that there are still an
older generation of vets that do
continue to offer declawing of cats even
when it's not medically necessary she
said in fact again this is what she said
when I spoke with her that there were
some veterinarians when people bring in
their cats to be spayed or neutered who
actually ask if if people want the cats
declawed while they're under anesthetic
she also strongly
argued that this well as she said in in
her uh in her letter that I circulated
that it's her strong opinion that the
state has a unique opportunity to use
the bill to support veterinarians in
their efforts to improve Animal Welfare
standards she said from her perspective
it is
um she would like if someone were to
come into her practice and ask for this
for her to be able to just say no it's
against the law uh and end the
conversation there
she also
um or I will say from from my own
perspective we did have a vet here who
testified I asked the the
that that witness that that vet if
the practice of decline cats unless it's
formatically necessary reason
if she concerted cruel and in my opinion
she had a very long pause
before she said no and provided a very
tortured response it was not at all a
convincing uh answer as far as I'm
concerned and then also for me
personally
we have laws on the books around animal
cruelty period we Define animal cruelty
in statute and if it's our determination
that this is a cruel practice uh then
like other examples of animal cruelty it
should be illegal so for those reasons
uh Madam chair I will support the Bill
thank you any other discussion
representative Bixby
yeah so
um two things about uh so
um I
I am hesitant to uh classify declawing
as animal cruelty uh because that
invokes another whole set of portion of
the criminal statute and I don't think
that it rises to that level
um
there is uh one thing that is different
about this bill from the ones we saw in
previous years is that uh it makes uh
decline of cats a violation rather than
being a criminal offense and I am
willing to supp I uh will be voting
against the itl because I am willing to
say um it makes sense
uh to as uh representative germano
pointed out uh provide some cover for uh
veterinarians who want to just be able
to say to their clients it's against the
law
thank you uh representative thank you
madam chair
I think
um what we heard in testimony and I
can't speak for all veterinarians and I
don't think any one veterinarian can
speak for all
but
from testimony that we heard from
several people and for me talking to
several vets they educate anybody that
walks into their office that wants a
declaw they do a really deep assessment
and for the most part they talk most of
those people out of that declaw however
there are going to be exceptions to the
rule and I believe it's between the
owner and the veterinarian
to make that determination for the
thank you yes representative germano
thank you very much Madam chair I
apologize I forgot to add something in
my previous comments I also want to
point out that I received a follow-up
email from uh from that vet pointing out
that the Centers for Disease Control no
longer recommend declawing of cats for
people who have blood clotting disorders
um there's also other kind of testimony
uh out there I don't know if this has
been circulated if everyone got it from
the from the Humane Society but from
um uh physician stating the same thing
that that was one of the things that
came up in the testimony which I
understand certainly was the concern for
people whose pets are very important to
them but they may have blood clotting
disorders because of medicine or or a
disease but in any event I just wanted
to to make that point that it is no
longer recommended by the CDC uh that
those folks have de-clead cats to
prevent them from
um
problems that might follow from being
scratched thank you madam chair thank
you for my own comments I'd like to say
that um
declawing cats are the only two states
that specifically prohibit decline by
Statute is New York and Maryland and
um seeing as I don't really see that as
an overwhelming problem here in New
Hampshire where you know many cats are
being declawed by veterinarians
I I will be supporting the itl motion
I don't believe that we need to really
put this in our statutes and
any other discussion
seeing none I would like the clerk to
call the roll on this vote thank you
madam chair we're voting on HB
231--fn and the motion is Ito
representative Creighton Creighton
represents uh is
Yayo
yay on Ito yes correct represent yes
representative Dolan yes
representative Arnold Davis
representative brilliad yes represent
coulon
uh representative smart
represent Bixby
Representative dutse no represent Murray
no
representative jamana
no representative Haskins no represent
Howard
Rosen NAB
represent Fred Davis
no
nine to nine Aaron oh oh Madam chair
okay
um who will be writing the committee
reports I believe uh representative
Creighton will be writing
and representative germano will be
writing
for the the OTP
um please get your reports into me as
soon as possible send them to me
electronically that would be helpful
thank you
and I will close the uh exec on HB 231
open up the exec on HB 37 establishing a
committee to study best practices for
companion animal groomers
and I would like to make the motion to
anybody second that I'll second that
thank you
and I will speak to that motion of
retaining that bill this bill we have
received some communication from Stacy
Ober of the American Kennel Club
and she indicated that
um
there were there are standard practices
that are available through AKC for
animal groomers and I reviewed them and
they looked pretty comprehensive
the suggestion from a few people
was that instead of having a committee a
study committee that we instead instruct
the Department of Agriculture to post
something up on their website
which indicates best practices for
animal groomers as well as a bulletin to
let consumers know what to look for in
animal groomers when they take their
pets to be groomed and I think that
makes good sense to put something out on
the Department of Agriculture website
so we will request them to do that and
in the meantime this bill can be
retained if in case we feel that we need
to do something more statutory set up a
committee or something else but I think
that this probably
uh solves the the question that was put
forth by this bill and I don't know if
there's any other comment that anybody
seeing none would you please call the
role Madam clerk to uh retain this Bill
thank you madam chair we're voting on HB
37 but the motion is to retain
representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative Dolan
yes
Arnold Davis
yes Reverend coulon
represent Kenny yeah
represent smart
represent Bixby
represent dutzie
represent Murray yes representative yes
representative Haskins yes
represent Howard representative NAB
representative Fred Davis
remember the VoIP yes 18-0 motion passes
hello oh Madam chair yes I'm so sorry
don't you vote for cotton
Madam chair do we want oh we don't need
to put this on consensus no thank you I
will close the execs for uh HB 37 and I
will open up the exact session for HB
relative to the acquisition of
agricultural land development rights
and representative Bixby I believe you
have a motion yes I'd like to
um
uh move ought to pass and make a a
move the adoption of amendment uh HB 221
and
um I'll and speak to that speak the
amendment briefly what is the number on
the amendment uh sorry amendment number
2023-0701h okay thank you okay so uh we
discussed we have a second oh do we wait
oh
sorry I'm sorry okay
okay so uh
all right you may now speak yes you may
go ahead thank you sorry about bumbling
that
um
so uh we discussed uh this amendment
fairly thoroughly this morning so I um I
don't think that a lot more needs to be
said I'm just uh I'd like to note that
this is going to be very useful for
helping preserve agricultural land in
the state and um
yeah
any other comments on this
Amendment
seeing none would you please call the
Royal Madam clerk thank you madam chair
this is to adopt amendment number
2023-071h
representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative Dolan
yes representative Arnold Davis
representative brouillon yes represent
coulon
represent Kenny represents smart
represent Bixby representative represent
Murray yes representative yes represent
Haskins yes represent Howard represent
NAB represent Fred Davis
represent Voight yes Madam chair yes
18-0 thank you the motion is adopted I
mean the amendment is adopted the
amendment is adopted do I hear a motion
for otpa yes representative Bixby I move
uh ought to pass with as amended with uh
Amendment
2023-0701 h
any other discussion
seeing none Madam clerk would you call
the roll thank you madam chair we're
voting on hb221
[Music]
otpa representative Creighton yay
represent yes representative Dolan yes
representative Arnold Davis
representative brouilliard yes represent
coulon represent Kenny
representative smart represent Bixby yes
represent dutzie representative Murray
representative yes representative
Haskins yes represent Howard
or is a NAB
represent Fred Davis
there's a Voit yes Madam chair yes 18-0
motion passes and do I hear uh that we
should put this on the consent calendar
without objection
thank you okay I will close the exec on
hb221 and open up the exec on hb119
that is relative to Homestead food
and representative comtwa I believe you
have an amendment that you'd like to
offer on this Bill thank you madam chair
I would like to move that we adopt
regarding House Bill 119
okay thank you
any discussion on this amendment uh
would you like to speak to the amendment
thank you madam chair
um this amendment is bringing uh we have
changed the original bill and we are
taking out
um the dollar amount for Homestead food
operations because after hearing
testimony there is no Enforcement issue
here and the original intent of the
original bill was supposed to be that it
was
um the amount was increased every year
regarding inflation and we just feel
that because there's no Enforcement
issue regarding this that the dollar
amount is does not need to be in there
representative Bixby
yes so um another aspect of this is that
uh
the this homestead exemption is
specifically for non-hazardous food and
it is for food that is sold only at
farmers markets at the farm at a farm
stand on the on sellers property or at
the seller's home and uh the
uh uh
in order to sell in venues broader than
that they would have to get licensed uh
the feeling was that
um one of one of the aspects of
uh this is that someone who wants to
have a broad to increase the business
would have to have a broader uh range of
selling and uh so there's a sort of an
automatic limit that just the scale of
operations would provide
and the the
um the monetary cap is kind of
irrelevant to that someone who's doing
jams would never get anywhere close to
seventy thousand dollars someone who was
doing wedding cakes might well go over
that uh it's the that amount is uh not
uh relevant to the purpose of making
sure that um
that there's appropriate food safety
safety oversight for things that go
beyond that narrow homestead exemption
okay thank you
all right any other questions or
comments regarding
um hb119 seeing none
um Madam clerk would you call the role
on the amendment thank you madam chair
2023-0629h representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative Dolan
yes representative Arnold Davis
represent brouliad yes represent coulon
represent Cannon Kenny uh representative
smart
represent Bixby yeah represent dutse
represent Murray representative Mana yes
represent Haskins yes represent Howard
represent NAB
represent Fred Davis
yes Madam chair yes 18-0 the amendment
is adopted
and do I hear
um a motion for otpa
Madam chair I'd like to make a motion to
otpa
.
C seconds
any discussion
seeing none
um would you call the role on otpa for
119. thank you madam chair
uh this is
otpa on House Bill 119 representative
Creighton yay representative yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Arnold Davis
represent Brouillard yes representative
Kenny
represent coulon
represents smart
represent Bixby represent dutzie
represent Murray representative yes
representative Haskins yes represent
Howard represent NAB representative Fred
Davis where's the Voigt yes Madam chair
yes 18-0
and without uh
uh well could we put this on the consent
calendar without objection
it does have a physical note I don't
know what the fiscal mode
yeah it's not a big enough fiscal note
and okay so I will close uh the exec on
hb119 and open up the exec on HB 122 and
do I hear a motion from representative
comtwa thank you madam chair I make a
motion to retain house bill 122. do I
hear a second
yeah thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair yes
although the bill itself is not ready
for prime time we have seen in recent
weeks articles in the paper where
um people are making food from their
farmers are making food and trying to
give it to those in need and can no
longer do that and I think this bill if
we retain it we can address some of
these issues and help food Security in
the state
okay any other discussion on this
seeing none would you please call the
roll on retain retaining hb122
thank you madam chair representative
Creighton yay where's the Contour yes
representative Dolan yes represent
Arnold Davis represent brouliad yes
represent coulon
Kenny
represents smart representative Bixby
representative Dotsy representative
Murray representative Mana yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard represent NAB
represent Fred Davis there's a Voit yes
okay
that bill is retained and I close the
exact session on that open up the exec
on HB 348 relative to the sale of raw
milk and products made with raw milk
yes Madam chair move to itl
representative Howard moves to itl do I
hear a second
oh second Madam chair thank you
representative Brouillard would you like
to speak to your motion please
representative Howard the prior law that
controls these has is barely a year old
so we'd like to give it time to see how
well it works and this is supported by
Health and Human Services food
Protective Services
any other comments representative Bixby
yeah I just um the there's been a fairly
long history with uh sorting things out
with raw milk and the key part of this
one was the raw milk ice cream and a our
former chair and long time member of the
committee John O'Connor The Honorable
John O'Connor um put a lot of work into
the bill that finally went into law last
term and uh that in in terms of making
sure that the risks involved in raw milk
did not
um
create any sort of a broad Hazard and uh
uh the uh representative or The
Honorable O'Connor was uh for a very
long time in the dairy industry so I'd
really trust his judgment and he felt
that on this bill uh was not appropriate
this time
thank you representative Murray thank
there are
um for very good reasons there are
unintended consequences should this bill
have moved forward so I support the
current motion on the floor
um in the interest of Public Health
thank you any other comments or
questions
seeing none would you please call the
Royal Madam Clerk thank you madam chair
this is to itl HB
348--fm representative Creighton yay
representative yes representative Dolan
yes representative Arnold Davis
representative Brouillard yes represent
coulon
represent Kenny representative smart
represent Bixby represent dutse yes
represent Murray represent jamana yes
represent Haskins yes representative
Howard represent NAB representative Fred
Davis where's the Voit yes Madam chair
yes 18-0 motion passes with no objection
I'd like to put this on consent
seeing none thank you
and I will close the exec on HB 348
and move on to opening up exec on HB 369
establishing a task force to provide
energy relief on farms
and do I hear a motion for that yes I
and I'd like to speak to the motion go
ahead okay so uh when we heard uh when
we heard this bill uh it was fairly
clear in the process of the hearing that
a task force was not going to really get
us where we wanted to be with this what
we really needed was to have
some person or entity that would be able
to help connect Farmers with the help
with with the assistance they needed in
order to get appropriate assistance
applying for uh energy uh uh so
um on Farm energy grants and whether
it's related to solar or wind or
um
more storage or efficiency
um and uh I had some conversations with
the
um with number of people and it all sort
of pointed in the direction of seeing if
this was something that we could work
with uh with Cooperative Extension I
spoke with the
um director of Cooperative Extension and
uh he explained the process that they
use for doing
education programs like the pesticide
so the pesticide licensing is done by
the Department of Agriculture but the
training for that is done by Cooperative
Extension on a contract basis and uh
the idea that we worked out was that
there could be someone in Cooperative
Extension who would be a field
specialist for energy purposes and there
would be a contract between the
Department of Agriculture and
Cooperative Extension to make that
possible this is something that we given
this would require an appropriation
of about about a hundred thousand
dollars which is about what it costs to
get a full-time person plus all the
benefits and all the travel expenses
Etc and
um
uh so uh that's something that wouldn't
be possible to bring to for us to get in
get into the build process uh or we
couldn't re because because it's got the
appropriation we couldn't do that uh
this year of this term but we could do
it uh in the second year of this term uh
and
um chairman Aaron uh spoke with the uh
chair of finance and uh got some
feedback that uh a hundred thousand
dollars for a purpose like this would
probably be available so this is
something we'll work on to re uh to
amend the bill in the fall and bring It
Forward again uh in bring it forward to
a vote uh early next year
thank you
seeing none uh Madam clerk would you
call the role to retain this Bill thank
you madam chair the vote is to retain HB
369 representative Creighton yay
represent yes represent Dolan yes
representative Arnold Davis
representative bullied yes represent
coulon represent Kenny represent smart
represent Bixby represent dutzie
represent Murray represent germana yes
representative Haskins yes
representative Howard represent NAB
representative Fred Davis
yes Madam chair yes 18-0
okay thank you
uh
I will close the exec session on that
bill
and open up the exact session on HB 493
eliminating the state meet inspection
program
do I hear emotion
thank you yeah yes I motion to retain HB
493 do I hear a second
representative Murray seconds and
would you like to speak to your motion
okay
representative Bixby
uh so this was my bill uh and
um
the there's a bill coming through the
Senate uh that is a study committee on
uh processing non-amentable meat uh and
Anonymous animals and
uh that uh there's a possibility that
that study committee will make
recommendations that would require there
is to still be or that would be easier
to deal with if we still have the Meat
Inspection program uh in the statute uh
because it's probably easier to amend
rather than to completely replace it so
um
in case we need this bill for uh for
further legislation related to that
study uh we I think it makes sense to
retain it and uh so um
yeah I agree thank you very much for
that and do we have any other question
or comment from the committee on that
bill
seeing none please Madam clerk call the
roll thank you madam chair we're voting
on uh to retain HB 493 representative
Creighton
yes representative Dolan yes represent
Arnold Davis represent brouliad yes
represent coulon represent Kenny we're
being smart represent Bixby represented
dutzie representative Murray represent
your Mana yes representative Haskins yes
represent Howard represent NAB
representative Fred Davis
represent Voigt yes Madam chair yes 18-0
motion passes thank you
close the exec on HB 493
we have on our schedule here to exec HB
um
we are probably going to be getting some
amendments on those two bills so they
are not ready to be exec today and I
will schedule
those two bills to be exec next week
uh in the morning so I will I don't know
if I have to open those up and recess
them or how does that work I think
so I guess uh open up HB 253 and I will
say that that bill will be exact next
week on um let's see what is it March
March 7th there you go March 7th and uh
in the morning
probably around 10 o'clock
so I I will recess that exec until then
and then I will open up hb56
and I will recess the exec for that bill
until March 7th at 10 A.M
and I will close that now as well we
have hb602
which is relative to landfill citing
and do I hear a motion representative
Bixby
yes I move that we retain
do I hear a second uh I will second that
actually
and would you speak to your motion yes
uh so
um this uh we have two bills that deal
with landfill citing this one and HB 56
we decided this morning that HB 56 would
be the better vehicle for us to use at
the moment uh and it's a possibility
that
um in the various discussions with uh
the other body about all the different
landfill bills coming forward uh we
might want to have a vehicle available
to put a bit put a bill in next uh next
year the second year of this term and uh
by retaining 602 we'll have a vehicle we
can amend it in any way that we wish
thank you any other questions or
seeing none uh Madam clerk could you
call the role on retaining hb602
thank you madam chair
the vote is to retain hb602
representative Creighton yay president
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Arnold Davis represent
brouilliard yes represent coulon
represent Kenny represent smart
represent Bixby yes represent dutse
represent Murray yes represent jamana
yes representative Haskins yes represent
Howard
represent NAB represent Fred Davis
representative yes Madam chair yes 18-0
motion passes
okay
um so we have uh a couple of bills HP
231 HB 221 hb119 HB 348
which
um I will need committee reports on so
please make sure you get them to me
and
again we will have an exec session next
week for HB 253 probably we'll do a
short
um
do we need a short committee work
session prior so that we can go over the
amendments
before we go into an exec session I
believe that would be an order yeah that
would make sense
so if we did
um
if we if we had our work session from
say 10 to 10 30
or both those bills uh or 10
huh
oh yeah we probably have um
work session and then maybe a short
caucus time and then exec and then we
would have our presentation by
um Tara said and Bob Hafner from
Council of state government so we can do
that in the morning and I'll figure out
the timing but please put in your
schedule that we will have a meeting
next Tuesday morning
okay
and
anybody have anything else to offer the
committee
again if you are going to be absent for
an exec session or a committee meeting
please let me or Peter Bixby know or
representative Creighton our vice chair
so that we know who will be in
attendance and who will not be in
attendance
and other than that I have nothing
further and I want to thank you all for
coming out on this very snowy day
um oh one other thing so with the um
with the animal groomers bill
I will draft up a letter from the
committee that would go to Commissioner
of Agriculture
requesting that um
some
document be put out on their website
regarding animal grooming practices as
well as a consumer guide for animal
groomers
consumers got a consumer guide for
people who are looking for animal
groomers and um I I will share that with
you all and before I send anything out
so
do you want to mention the letter to uh
the board of customer the pesticide
control board on uh oh sure we had a
letter that uh
yes thank you for the reminder
so our
yes
um our committee researcher took uh some
words that uh representative Bixby put
together and put it on letterhead
um
um would you like to read that letter
representative Bixby
um did you get a copy of it
there's an electronic copy there's an
electronic copy oh I don't
no
um
Ms Grant do you have do you have a copy
yeah sit up at the there and just read
it to us and let everybody know what
and this is in relation to the
rodenticide bill correct
yeah
okay so this is to commissioner Jasper
dear commissioner Jasper the house
environment and agricultural committee
received a bill HB 326 proposing a ban
on second generation anticoagulant
rodenticides sgars with some specific
exemptions
the impetus for the bill was animal
rehabilitation centers observing an
increase in cases of wild animals
suffering anticoagulant poisoning we
heard from environmental organizations
and Wildlife rehabilitators who
testified that poisoned rodents before
they die make easy prey for Raptors and
other carnivores and that the corpses
pose a poisoning threat for carrion
eaters we heard from other witnesses
that rodent infestations particularly
rat infestations can be very difficult
to control with alternate methods on
February 7th commissioner Jasper
informed the committee that the
pesticide control board is convening a
stakeholder working group that will
include among others representative of
the New Hampshire veterinary diagnostic
laboratory and a representative of the
New Hampshire Wildlife Rehabilitation
organizations the working group will be
charged with Gathering and assessing
data regarding Wildlife exposure to
sgars and developing a solution for this
problem one possible approach would be
classifying sgars as restricted use the
house environment and agricultural
agriculture committee fully supports the
work of the working group we have
retained HP 26 326 if the working group
finds a resolution to the problem that
can be achieved within current statute
through rulemaking the bill can be
recommended itl when we review it in the
fall if on the other hand further
legislation will be necessary to resolve
the issue HB 326 will be available as a
vehicle for that legislation the
committee extends its appreciation to
the pesticide control board for the work
it does to make sure that pesticides are
used responsibly in New Hampshire
sincerely and then committee on
environment and agriculture Judy Aaron
chairman okay are we all good with that
wonderful okay do you want me to email
it to the committee just so you have yes
please
I don't know do you need me to sign a
okay wonderful I can do that before I
leave this afternoon
sure
if I can take a moment of I guess
personal privilege to congratulate rep
brute yard on
um congratulations
so so tell us the details
so I have um two girls already both
eight and six uh
side have our third child his name is
Logan
eight pounds even which is you don't
really see an even uh on a baby but uh
yeah just over 20 inches uh he's doing
very good healthy everyone's happy tired
but
um we're all doing good thank you very
much I appreciate it thank you
say again
uh he's born on President's Day
very well well congratulations from us
all
thank you
all right
foreign